They say he's been dead a long time Come let us go to the sepulcher To put me out here for I'm scared Bring me to nobody's grave Kevin now watch how you open the coffin now. He's been dead 300 years wait You know me honey boom These children to me
他们说他已经死了很久了 来吧 让我们去墓穴 把我留在这儿因为我很害怕 把我带到一个无名墓地 凯文 现在看好你是怎么打开棺材的。他已经死了300年了 等等 你懂我的 亲爱的轰 这些孩子对我
Wait now wait wait wait Wait, wait, see? He winking when I hide. He livin', he livin' in Lesseran. Hey, this is Joel with the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast. Today we're going to talk about the psychology of death, which we'll get into in a minute. I'm here with Alice, co-host and Taproot therapist, and then Kearney Smith. And Kearney is appearing actually because he is dead. Like a while ago, he was declared legally dead. And then since then, he's been able to see through the veil to the other side.
等等 现在 等等 等等 等等，等等，看到了吗？我躲藏时他眨了眼。他还活着，他活在勒瑟兰。嘿，我是乔尔，欢迎来到主根疗法集体播客。今天我们要聊聊死亡心理学，我们一会儿就会深入探讨。和我在一起的是联合主持兼主根治疗师爱丽丝，还有卡尼·史密斯。卡尼来这儿是因为他其实已经死了。就在不久前，他被宣告在法律上死亡。从那以后，他就能透过面纱看到彼岸。
Not really. Just kidding. I don't know. I sort of relate to that. Yeah. Yeah. Or maybe, maybe. Actually, you know, one of the problems with death is that we don't know what happens. You can't really see past it. You know, there's some good guesses that people have made. Until now, Kearney actually has a 12-step program that he's selling. It's pretty expensive, you know, but for knowledge like that, that's pretty valuable. So I'm only, I'm just an adeptus praetorium, like I'm on level three and the orange belt. So anyway, he's going to tell us about that. And we're going to be disbanding our business to follow him across the country as he seeks converts.
其实没有。开玩笑的。我不知道。我有点能感同身受。是啊。是啊。或者也许，也许。其实，你知道，死亡的问题之一在于我们不知道会发生什么。你真的无法看透它。你知道，人们曾有过一些很好的猜测。直到现在，卡尼其实有一个他正在出售的12步课程。挺贵的，你知道，但为了这样的知识，这相当有价值。所以我只是，我只是一个进阶古罗马执政官级，就像我在第三级和橙带。总之，他会跟我们讲讲这个。我们将解散我们的业务，跟随他走遍全国，寻找皈依者。
Well, I mean, taproot necromancy is going to be nice. Just kidding. He's a nurse. He's one of the smartest guys that I know. He also will get into his story, but he is very interested in to, you know, death as a symbol and death as a practical reality. And I'm really glad that there are people cut out to be friends with me. So thank you for sharing on our podcast um and i mean i think like when we talking about this you know like you know the practical realities of the the funeral
好吧，我的意思是，主根亡灵巫术应该挺不错的。开玩笑的。他是个护士。他是我认识最聪明的人之一。他待会儿也会讲讲他的故事，但他对死亡作为一种象征以及死亡作为一种现实非常感兴趣。我真的很高兴有人天生就适合做我的朋友。所以谢谢你在我们的播客上分享 呃，我的意思是，我觉得当我们谈论这个时，你知道，你知道现实中葬礼的
situations of our current times and then a lot of different traditions of the past of just practical what do you do when somebody dies um and then also death is kind of like a symbol or you know psychological reality so i don't know where the discussion will go. For people who are tuning in on the podcast and not on the video, to really get into this episode, I'm wearing black lipstick. I also have a t-shirt with a tire track down it and some 2004 jeans with lots of zippers that are black and a Nightmare Before Christmas branded fedora.
我们这个时代的现状，以及过去许多关于“当有人去世时你该怎么做”的实际传统的不同传统，嗯，还有死亡有点像是一种象征，或者你知道的心理现实，所以我不知道讨论会走向何方。对于在播客上收听而不是看视频的听众，为了真正融入这一集，我涂了黑色口红。我还穿了一件印有轮胎印的T恤，还有一些2004年的牛仔裤，上面有很多黑色的拉链，以及一顶圣诞夜惊魂品牌的费多拉帽。
So I really went all out to get ready for it. Courtney's eyeballs are popping out like a wolf. So his tongue's on the table and he's clapping. He's clapping as he sees. I'm slamming my fist on the table and going to the WUGA. I'm just long. His bow tie is spinning around. Yeah, my bow tie is spinning.
所以我真的是全力以赴为它做准备。考特尼的眼珠子像狼一样突出来。所以他的舌头搭在桌上，他在鼓掌。他看到时在鼓掌。我一拳砸在桌子上，喊着WUGA。我只是长。他的领结在转圈。对，我的领结在转。
There was a rug under him just a minute ago. Now it's shot behind him all right okay kerny so uh i'll start with when me and my wife went to louisiana um we were looking at the beautiful like above ground cemeteries that are so affecting and interesting as your counter practical reality that there's flooding so you have to keep the bodies in a box because if you just bury them they'll float back up to the top and we were coming back and we were like how does this work like what do you keep putting new ones in or like okay how many can you stack it i was like i bet kerny knows the answer to this question and um we called kerny and about an hour
就在刚才，他身下还有一张地毯。现在它被弹到他身后了，好了，好吧，卡尼，呃，我从我和我妻子去路易斯安那州开始讲起，呃，我们看到了那些美丽的地上公墓，它们非常有感染力且有趣，作为对“会发生洪水，所以你必须把尸体放在盒子里，因为如果你直接埋了它们，它们会浮回顶部”这一现实情况的应对，而我们回来时就在想，这到底是怎么运作的？比如你是不断把新的放进去，还是，好吧，你能叠放多少层？我就想，我敢说卡尼知道这个问题的答案，呃，我们给卡尼打了电话，大约一个小时
and 20 minutes later uh we knew a lot of things about that but one of the things i didn't know about you that came up in that conversation is that you wanted to be a mortician you can talk about your your journey and fascination with with death yeah um i think i mean just ever since i was little i think um i want to say my first encounters with death when i was little honestly scared the bejesus out of me um i remember going to a funeral for a distant relative and just finding the whole thing. Of course, at the time, I didn't think this, but looking back, it was this very weird Kubrickian moment of walking into this room with this bizarre lighting
20分钟后，呃，我们对那里的很多事情有了了解，但关于你，我以前不知道而在那次对话中浮现出来的一件事情是，你曾想成为一名殡仪师，你可以谈谈你的这段经历以及对死亡的迷恋吗？是的，呃，我想，我的意思是，自从我小的时候起，我想，呃，我想说我小时候对死亡的初次经历，老实说，把我吓得魂飞魄散，呃，我记得去参加一个远亲的葬礼，只是觉得整件事……当然，当时我没这么想，但回想起来，这是一种非常诡异的库布里克式的时刻，走进这个有着奇异灯光的房间，
and just barely seeing this dead guy's nose just poking up over the rim of the casket and just thinking, this is so weird and uncomfortable. And then when it happened to close relatives, of course, that was super upsetting, but I think part of my defense mechanism to that was just turning into an interest instead. So there was a little while where I was going to,
勉强能看到那个死者的鼻子从棺材边缘露出来，然后就在想，这太诡异、太让人不舒服了。然后当这种事发生在至亲身上时，当然，那超级令人沮丧，但我认为我的防御机制之一就是把这变成了一种兴趣。所以有一小段时间，我打算，
I was going to go to school, be a mortician. And the thing that stopped it for me is honestly, I'm just, I don't know. I don't think I'm a ruthless enough salesman to be a good like funeral director. A lot of that, you do have to basically just like own and operate business that or get involved with a corporate you know funeral home business and that gets yeah i find it all very predatory and i mean to to be granted like modern medicine is also kind of predatory in some ways but but but it is very very much particularly in the funeral
我打算去上学，成为一名殡仪师。而真正让我打消这个念头的是，老实说，我只是，我不知道。我觉得我没有足够冷酷的推销手段，成不了一个优秀的殡仪馆馆长。这里面很大一部分工作，你基本上必须自己拥有并运营那样的一家生意，或者卷入公司化的，你知道的，殡仪馆业务，而那让我觉得，呃，我发现这一切都极具掠夺性，我的意思是，平心而论，现代医学在某些方面其实也具有某种掠夺性，但是，但是，特别是殡仪
industry there is there is a very big big financial incentive to kind of screw you over. Yeah. When people are at their worst time, too. Yeah. That's the thing I can't do. I can't. I can't. I can't.
行业，这里面存在着非常非常大的经济动机，有点像是在坑你。是啊。当人们处于最糟糕的时期时也是。是啊。这就是我做不到的事。我不能。我不能。我不能。
That's the idea of like someone who's just lost their parent and me just like Big Lebowski style being like it's modestly priced receptacle. I was thinking about dropping that in right there, that clip. Just because we're bereaved doesn't make us sad! Sir, please lower your voices. Man, don't you have something else we can put them in?
这就好比某个刚刚失去父母的人，而我像《谋杀绿脚趾》里的那样，说：“这是一个售价适中的容器。”我当时就想把这个片段放进那里面，就在那个位置。仅仅因为我们在悲伤并不意味着我们不难过！先生，请降低音量。老兄，难道你就没有别的什么东西可以把他们放进去吗？
That's an exact thing. And that's just sick. At least as a nurse, I that like i'm trying to help people get better um and i don't know like who knows down the down the line like i don't know if they ever start really getting big into like eco burials like i could see myself retraining to maybe do eco-friendly embalmings that would be a lot of fun and the process like i already got kind of a leg up on it. Yeah, that was the original,
这完全是一回事。这太恶心了。至少作为一名护士，我觉得，呃，我是在试图帮助人们好起来，呃，我不知道，谁知道以后会怎么样，呃，我不知道他们是否会真正开始大力推广生态葬之类的——我能看到自己重新接受培训，也许去做生态友好的防腐处理，那会非常有意思，而且这个过程——我已经在这方面有点优势了。对，那是最初的，
that was the genesis for this, is we wanted to interview the author, and she wasn't available. But there's a lot of critique now. Caitlin Doughty? Yeah, yeah, she's so good. And if you can't get a hold of her, like, she's got... She's on sabbatical. So we'll try again next year. Ah, yeah. Well, I mean, I will be honest. A lot of stuff I know has also been from like watching.
那是这一切的起源，我们本想采访这位作家，但她没空。但现在有很多批评。凯特琳·道蒂？对，对，她太棒了。如果你联系不上她，你看，她有……她在休假。所以我们明年再试一次。啊，是的。好吧，我的意思是，说实话，我了解到的很多东西也是通过观看……
And her book, From Here to Eternity, is fantastic. Like she does a lot of good stuff. And it's also in very much into the like the eco burial movement which i think is really cool because i mean much like everything else like the modern american funeral industry is not sustainable and and it's um yeah between it not being sustainable and also just by its nature kind of being predatory it's like look we kind of we need to shift the system around i mean like most things but and i think you mean by not sustainable not that it's like total zero carbon or or you know totally green or something you mean like it is something excuse me i need a cough button um not possible to do
还有她的书《此生：关于死亡与终结的奇妙旅程》太棒了。她做了很多很棒的事。而且它也非常符合生态葬运动，我觉得这真的很酷，因为，我的意思是，就像其他所有事情一样，现代美国殡仪行业是不可持续的，而且它是，呃，介于它不可持续以及它本质上的掠夺性之间，这就好像是，看，我们需要改变这个系统，我的意思是，就像大多数事情一样，我想你所说的不可持续并不是指它是完全零碳的，或者你知道的，完全绿色的什么的，你的意思是这是一种——不好意思，我需要一个咳嗽按钮——可能在另外20年内都无法做到，可能像资源的消耗加上，是的，特别是在美国。我的意思是，我们有这么多的土地，你知道，你可以开辟一个巨大的公墓，却依然有墓地，而在欧洲，他们不这么做，比如在德国。当你买一块墓地时，你租用这块墓地一段时间，我想说大约15到20年。别把这当成我的原话，但这足够让躺在里面的人完全瓦解并彻底分解。然后它就会对新来的人开放。德国是个小国。他们不能再那样使用了。
probably for another 20 years probably a company like the expenditure of resources plus like, yeah, particularly in the United States. I mean, we have so much land that, you know, you can get away with like opening up a whole big cemetery and still have plots like in Europe. They don't do that in Germany, for example. Like when you buy a plot, you rent that plot for a period of, I want to say, 15 to 20 years. Don't quote me on that, but it's just long enough for whoever's in there to break down and decompose fully. And then it's open to new arrivals. Germany is a small country. They're not using it anymore.
是的。抱歉，请继续。他们会叠放它们吗？那是怎么运作的？他们会叠放棺材吗？他们怎么让别人使用这块墓地的？我想部分原因在于他们也挖得很深。通常，我认为至少一些欧洲公墓也会有一个总骨灰堂，用来容纳骨骼遗骸。
Yeah. Sorry, go ahead. Do they stack them? How does that work? Do they stack baskets? How do they let somebody else use the plot? I think part of it is they also dig deep. Typically, I think at least some European cemeteries, they also will have a general ossuary where they'll contain the bone remains.
他们会把骨头挖出来，放进总骨灰堂。所以你爱的人仍然在公墓里。他们只是在公墓的某种集体生活空间里，这就有点像纪念花园，你有一块瓷砖纪念这个人，但骨灰撒在了花园里。是的，好吧，而且再次说明，这只是一种情况：我们现在非常幸运，有足够的土地，老实说，可以相当浪费地使用它，但这大概不是长久之计，你不能一直这样做。所以你们将不得不寻找新的出路。我的意思是，最近一个绝佳的虚构例子，因为
They'll exhume the bones, put them in the general ossuary. So your loved one's still in the cemetery. They're just in, like, the communal living space of the cemetery that's kind of how a memorial garden is that you have a tile you know commemorating the person but the ashes are scattered into the garden yeah well it's and again it's just it's a thing of we we are very fortunate now that we have like enough land to honestly be fairly wasteful with it but it's like that's not probably long term you can't keep doing that. So you're going to have to find something new. I mean, a great fictional example recently, because
我看了珍妮玩了相当多的，这会是一个奇怪的题外话，但我发誓这跟这个有关。你喜欢这里的那些吗？我一直在看珍妮玩《赛博朋克2077》，她特别地，我记得，在某个时候把我叫了过去。
I've watched Jenny play through a fair bit of, this is going to be a weird digression, but I swear it relates to this. You like those on here? I've been watching Jenny play Cyberpunk 2077, and she specifically, I remember, called me in at one point.
我就说：“嘿，卡尼，来看看这个。”然后她向我展示了他们在游戏中拥有的公墓。这非常酷，因为就像你在未来没有足够的空间埋葬所有人一样。所以这一切都只是一个巨大的骨灰龛。这是一个个小格子里存放着人们的骨灰。那是给每个人的。这只是一排排延伸的、像巨石一样的骨灰龛，一直延伸到远方，非常酷的画面，也是一种非常有创意的处理方式，是的，这大概就是你将不得不应对这种情况的方式。
I was like, hey, Kearney, come take a look at this. And she was showing me the cemetery that they have in-game. And it is very cool because it's like you don't have enough room to bury everyone in the future. So it's all just one gigantic, like, columbarium. It's little slots where people's ashes get. That's for everyone. It's just these stretching, like, monoliths of columbariums going off to the distance really cool image and also just a very creative way of like yeah that is probably how you're gonna have to deal with this
有一周我在诊所做眼动身心重建法（brainspotting），呃，我们不经常使用的资源技巧之一是大卫·格兰（David Grand）制作的眼动音乐，它在左耳和右耳之间缓缓来回播放，但以一种你的大脑无法预测的速度，而且它在不断变化。然后，呃，我在设备上按错了按钮。
there was a there was a week where i was doing brain spotting at the clinic and um one of the resourcing things we don't use all the time is the brain spotting music that david grand made where it slowly goes back and forth between year to year, but at a kind of rate, your brain can't predict and it changes. And, um, I had a wrong button on the device.
所以有一周，我给所有做眼动身心重建法的人播放了《赛博朋克2077》的原声带，呃，人们纷纷表示，这音乐挺诡异的。这就好象，
And so there was like a week where I played the cyberpunk 2770, uh, soundtrack for everybody doing brain spotting. And, uh, people were being like, this music's pretty weird. It's like,
是的，大卫是个怪人。你知道，他弹吉他。他写了这些歌，但听起来就像基努·里维斯在唱摇滚，所以我后来澄清了，大家都觉得挺逗的。爱丽丝，你有没有，呃，任何关于死亡的初次经历，或者对死亡、葬礼故事的想法？我不知道，为了引出你的视角，我没有……第一次接触死亡或对死亡的想法、葬礼故事？我不知道。为了引出你的视角。
yeah, David's an odd guy. You know, he played guitar. He wrote those songs but it was like keanu reeves singing rock so i clarified it later got a kick out of that alice you have uh any kind of first experience with death or thoughts on death funeral story any i don't know to kind of kick off your perspective i don't it the first experience with death or thoughts on death, funeral story? I don't know. To kind of kick off your perspective.
我没有。初次经历就是……这有点像它没有。就像，我记得自己很小的时候。或者，我的意思是，也许直到，比如，初中左右，觉得大年长者对死亡小题大做是一件很奇怪的事。比如，在那些年纪，我当时就想，这有什么大不了的？你只是不在了而已。而且我不知怎么有一种感觉，就像我五年前不在这里，或者你知道的，昨天不在，这没什么大不了的。
I don't. The first experience is it's sort of like it doesn't. Like, I remember being really little. Or, I mean, maybe up until, like, middle school or something, feeling like it was weird that grownups made such a big deal out of death. Like, at those ages, I was like, what's the big deal? You're just not here anymore. And I somehow had some sense that it was like I wasn't here five you just you're just not here anymore and i somehow had some sense that it was like i wasn't here five years ago or you know yesterday not a big deal
是的，呃，我不确定这是一种常见的感觉，还是那种像小孩子一样的感觉，呃，我的理论是，小孩子对成年人围绕某些事情的情绪的反应，要多于他们内生地、只是以某种方式学会的，他们来到这个世界上，在真空中对这些事情做出反应。我的意思是，每个人都是不同的，但我认为很多……我的意思是，为什么文化在另一个地方会有所不同呢？你知道的，你在学习人们对这些事情如何反应，以及它们在你的生活中扮演什么角色，你知道的，比如一个神话，或者随便什么，你知道的，基于人们如何谈论某事或不谈论它。是的。我有……我认识我的曾祖父母，他们住在乡下很远的地方，有点像，
yeah um and i'm not sure if that's a common common feeling or if that was like in children but um my theory is that children react to adults emotion around things more than they endogenously just kind of learn they come into the world reacting these things in a vacuum i mean everyone's different but and i think a lot of the i mean why would culture be different in another place you know you're learning how people react to these things and what their role in your life is you know like a myth or you know whatever you know based on how people talk about something or don't talk about it. Yeah. I had, I knew my great grandparents and they lived way out in the country and were kind of,
我想是美南浸信会那类背景。我记得那些祖父母中的每一个大约在我上六年级、五年级或四年级时去世。所以年龄已经大到足以让我真正记住了。但我，但我记得……我记得我们唱的圣歌。我记得我曾祖母葬礼上我们唱的是哪首圣歌。然后我还记得
I guess like Southern Baptist sort of background. And I remember each of those grandparents dying around when I was like sixth grade or fifth or fourth grade. So old enough for me to really remember. But I, but what I, what I remember the hymns that we sang. I remember what hymn we sang at my great-grandmother's funeral. And then I remember
棺材当时是开着还是关着，这有点搞笑，因为就像我祖母，他们的女儿，真的很希望他们的葬礼是开棺瞻仰的，因为那是社区所期望的，但就像我们这一代人，还有我……或者我父母这一代人——比如我母亲，那是她去世的祖母——还有她的阿姨，他们对此感到有些尴尬，并且总是……在家族里拐弯抹角地谈论举行开棺瞻仰仪式是多么俗气，你知道的，所以他们就像是……会有这种非常奇怪的对话，讨论关于死亡的事情是否俗气，我不知道，是的。是的，我的经历有点像，我记得，呃，当我还是个孩子的时候，
whether or not the caskets were open or not, which was sort of funny because it was like my grandmother, their daughter, really wanted an open casket for their funerals because it was what the communities would expect but it was like our generation and my or my parents generation like my mother who it was her grandmother who had died and her sister they were sort of mortified about it and felt and we're always and we're kind of talking sideways in the family about how tacky it was to have an open casket you know so they're just like this very weird kind of conversations that would go on like as to whether that's i mean whether something to do with death is tacky or not i don't yeah yeah i that was kind of my experience was i remember um when i was a kid
就像那种阈限状态，一直对那东西很感兴趣，还有当事情表现得像“哦，我们得假装这说得通，但我们都知道根本说不通”时的那种讽刺意味，我总是那种，等一下，你知道的，作为一个孩子，可能现在仍然是，你知道的，带有那种许多恶作剧原型。但我的高祖母在她100岁生日的前一天去世了，所以我们打算去，呃，埋葬她，然后，呃……她我想有一半是吉普赛血统，一半是美洲原住民，我是纯血切罗基人，所以她的父母，或者她的母亲——我想她不认识她的父亲——她的母亲非常，呃，漂泊不定，有点像那种来到镇上修锅补盆的人。就像她那一支来自贫困家庭。
like just kind of liminality and was always sort of interested in that and also just irony when things was like oh we have to pretend like this makes sense but we all know it doesn't i was always kind of like wait a minute you know as a kid and and probably still am you know a lot of that trickster archetype but my great great grandmother died the day before her 100th birthday and so we were gonna go uh to bury her and the um she was i think half gypsy and half uh native american i'm full of cherokee and so her parents or her mother i don't think she knew her father her mother was like very uh transient and kind of like came to town and fix pots and stuff. Like she came from poverty on that side.
然后她嫁给了一个拥有……他是基督会牧师的儿子，呃，我的高曾祖夫。然后还有他的家族在这个镇上拥有磨坊，那个镇已经不在了，但那就像是有史以来最大的一次阶层跃升。
And then she married the guy who owned, he was the son of the church of Christ priest, um, my great, great grandfather. And then also his family on the grist mill in this town that is not there anymore, but it was like the biggest like upgrade ever.
就像她在1920年凭一己之力把你想要的生活中的一切都创造了出来，而且，呃，就像他们，呃，那里，
Like she made whatever you, you know, wanted out of life in 1920. And, um, like they, uh, there,
所以上面有一个家族墓地，但小镇已经消失了。所以就像，我们不得不付费去清理它，然后从没有人见过它。我们不得不开车上山去那里，大概是最后一次，我的意思是，我可以，我想如果我想的话我可以被埋在那里。
so there's a family cemetery up there, but the town's gone. So it's like, we had to pay to clear it and then no one's ever seen it. And we had to drive up there probably the last, I mean, I could, I guess I could be buried there if I wanted to.
家族里的任何人都可以，呃，但它只是在一座山上，那里曾经有个小镇，现在已经没了。所以其中的讽刺意味真的很棒，就好像，这是墓地里最重要的事情。它本该永远存在。然后它成了荒野。它消失了。它被收回了。
Anybody in the family could be, um, but it's just on a mountain where there used to be a town that's gone. And so the irony of that was really neat, where it was just like, this was the most important thing ever in the cemetery. It's supposed to last forever. And then it's wilderness. It's gone. It's been reclaimed.
然后去那里，开辟出它来。每个人从小都听过各种故事。我们不知道他是谁的叔叔还是什么的，但查理叔叔在1918年左右还是个孩子时，沿着一辆火车奔跑，然后摔倒了，接着胳膊被火车轧断了，这真是一个问题，因为对于那个支派的基督会来说，肉身的复活意味着你需要你的肉体。不仅仅是你的灵魂，
And then going there, carving it out. And everyone had grown up hearing stories. We don't know whose uncle he was or whatever, but Uncle Charlie was running along a train when he was a kid in 1918 or something and fell and then had his arm cut off by the train, which is a problem because for that branch of Church of Christ, the resurrection of the flesh means that you need your meat body. It's not just your soul,
复活时你要以某种方式从地下爬起来。所以你必须有你的胳膊。那条胳膊在查理被埋葬前几十年就被埋葬了，所以我们一直在找它，我们找到了像查理某某的墓地，旁边有一个小墓碑，标记着胳膊在哪里，他们把它放下的地方。然后只是去……然后你知道的，就像我的祖母，我的阿姨有点抱怨不得不为我祖母花钱。她年纪大了以后有点老古董和神经质。
that the resurrection you get up out of the ground somehow. And so you have to have your arm. the arm was buried before charlie was buried by you know a couple decades and so we were looking for it and we found like a cemetery of charlie somebody and there was a little tombstone next to it that had marked where the arm was where they put it down and so just being and then you know just like my grandmother, my aunt was kind of complaining about having to spend money on my grandmother. She was kind of older and neurotic when she was older.
她就说：“哦，看看那套衣服。她会喜欢那套衣服的。我给她买成了她想要的那套。”她已经死了。所有这些都在我脑子里打转。这真是一个疯狂的概念。欧文·亚隆说，盯着太阳看，它有点影响着一切，但你不能直视它。这真是一个疯狂的概念。欧文·亚隆说盯着太阳看。它有点影响着一切，但你不能直视它。
She was like, oh, look at the suit. She would have loved that suit. I've got her the one she wanted. She's dead. All of it was just kind of going around in my brain. It's just kind of a wild concept. Irving Jollim says, staring at the sun, it's kind of affecting everything, but you can't look right at it. just kind of a wild concept. Irving Jollim says staring at the sun. It's kind of affecting everything, but you can't look right at it.
你真的无法看透它。其实回到爱丽丝的观点，我真的嘲笑那些大放厥词的人，说什么举行开棺瞻仰太俗气了。
You can't really see it. Going back actually to Alice's point about I really laughed at people throwing shade and oh, it's tacky to have an open test.
这真是太美妙的人性了。在别人的葬礼上，你还是忍不住八卦和轻浮。不过，关于人们随着时间改变或者越来越多的人选择闭棺葬礼，这是一个有趣的观点，
That's so wonderfully human. You can't help but still be gossipy and flippy at someone's funeral. That is a funny point, though, regarding people that changing over time or more people are having closed casket funerals
因为围绕着亲眼瞻仰这样一具遗体对心理健康究竟是否有益，目前存在着争论。这是否——殡仪馆行业所宣称的你可以得到的“记忆画面”——真的对你有帮助？还是说，看到这个人处于更自然的死亡状态，让他们呈现出死亡的力量，看起来确实有些松弛，这会更有帮助？这之所以更能提供帮助，仅仅是因为它能让你抽离出来并意识到：是的，这个人
because there is a debate surrounding whether actually viewing a body like that is psychologically healthy or not. Whether that, what the funeral industry claims is a memory picture that you get. Is that actually helpful for you? Or would it be more helpful to see this person in a more natural state of death where they have the power of death, where they do look slack? Like, does that help more simply because that allows you to kind of decouple and realize, like, yes, this person
已经走了。他们现在只剩下物理上的肉体了。当然，他们在许多现代葬礼上的做法是让你去寻找它。他们让你看起来尽可能栩栩如生。他们专门在棺材正上方装了灯，
is gone. They are now just the physical meat left. And, of course, the way they do it in a lot of modern funerals is they make you look for it. They make you look as lifelike as possible. They have specifically lights right above the caskets
向下照射出非常柔和的小粉红色灯光，这大大美化了大自然。我其实最近有过这方面的经历，因为我的祖母不久前因长期重病去世了。当时的情况是，她去世时我不在场。对我而言，去见她最后一面其实非常有用。能够……而且那是一次私人的瞻仰。字面意思就是我走进去，然后我就想，是的，他们为我打开了棺材。
that shine down these very nice little pink lights that saw nature tremendously. I actually had a recent experience with it because my grandmother very recently passed away from a long, long illness. And it was the kind of thing where I was not there when she passed. And for me, it was actually very helpful to go see her one last time. Like, to be able to... And it was just a private view. It was literally where I went in there. I was just like, yeah, they have the casket open for me.
我很快地看了一眼桑德拉。这有助于给我带来一些内心的抚慰。我知道这对我很有帮助，但我也确实知道……我们处理这件事的方式是否真的有帮助，这是一个有趣的、尚未定论的争论。它被过分修饰和风格化了。当我们打电话向你询问那些仪式是如何运作的，我的意思是，你基本上是从南北战争讲起的。你说，嗯，美国殡仪行业的开端是南北战争，因为有那么多尸体必须运送跨越全国，而且那是以前从未有过的。
I could see Sandra real quick. And that helped bring me some closure. I know that helped me, but I do know it's also... It is an interesting open debate as to the way that we do it. It's so dolled up and stylized, whether that's actually helpful or not. And when we had called you to ask about how those scripts functioned, I mean, you started basically with the Civil War. You were like, well, the beginning of the funeral industry in America was the Civil War because there are all these bodies that had to be shipped across the country and that had never been seen before.
所以他们开始把毒药注入他们体内，这对于把他们运回家来说真的很糟糕。我的意思是，不是要上一堂巨大的历史课，但你能给我们讲讲殡仪行业诞生的实际情况吗？好的，而且我对这段历史并不是了如指掌。所以任何观众，如果有谁想指正我，请尽管来。我无法保证我的准确性，但，是的，它确实开始了。向护理委员会投诉。别……观众，如果你们想指正我，请尽管来。我无法保证我的准确性，但，是的，它确实开始了。向护理委员会投诉。别给我发电子邮件。对，求求你们，请别针对我，求求了。
So they started to fill them up with poison, which was really bad to get them back home. I mean, not to do a huge history lesson, but can you give us like a little bit of the practical realities of the birth of the funeral industry? OK, so and I don't know this history backwards and forwards. So any any viewers, if you want to call me out, please do. I can't guarantee my accuracy, but yeah, it did start. File a complaint with the nursing board. Don't viewers, if you want to call me out, please do. I can't guarantee my accuracy, but yeah, it did start. File a complaint with the nursing board. Don't send me an email. Yeah, please, please don't at me, please.
但，是的，它或多或少是因为在南北战争期间，战场上有太多的尸体，如果你有资源的话，唯一真正实际能做的事就是把他们就地掩埋。因为，是的，
But yeah, it did start more or less because during the Civil War, there were so many bodies on the battlefield that it was like the only practical thing you could do really was just bury them right practical thing you could do, really, was just bury them right there if you had the resources. Because, yeah,
特别是这里南方的战役，抱歉，在盛夏时节，尸体开始发作，它们会立刻开始分解，在那个国家里。而且试图用火车把尸体运回家也是一个极其严重的问题。火车开始表示：不，我们不运送
particularly in the campaigns here in the South, like, I'm sorry, in the midst of summer, like, bodies are going to start going, they're going to start decomposing, like, immediately in that country. And there was a tremendous problem also trying to ship bodies home on trains. Trains started to be like, no, we're not taking
任何更多的腐烂尸体了。对不起，太恶心了。是的，我们不处理这东西。所以最终，我想，他叫什么名字来着？我想不起来了。防腐之父，
any more rotting corpses. I'm sorry, it's nasty. Yeah, we're not handling this thing. So eventually, I think, what was his name? I can't remember. The father of embalming,
我们说话的时候我可以在旁边查一下。但他们开始用砷溶液给尸体防腐，当然，这非常有效，但也很容易让自己因砷中毒。对土地也没有好处，对吧？是的，是的。地下水。是的。我的意思是，某种程度上现代防腐化学品也是如此，比如甲醛——甲醛我的意思是，它们通常具有相当大的致癌性。但是，但是，是的，旧式的防腐使用砷，这相当恶心。
I'll look it up on the side while we're talking. But they began embalming corpses using an arsenic solution, which, of course, is very effective, but it's also very easy to make yourself sick with arsenic. Not against the ground either? Yeah, yeah. Ground water. Yes. And I mean, same thing to a certain degree with with modern embalming chemicals like flameldehyde formula is I mean, they are generally pretty carcinogenic. And but but yeah, old styles of embalming used arsenic, which is pretty nasty.
他们很快意识到，这不是一种安全的方法。让我们尝试点别的。而且不仅在整个历史上，甚至在现代防腐中，都有许多不同风格的防腐。我想，关于如何做到这一点，有几种不同的看法，直到那种现代的动脉防腐方法出现，基本上你有一个进水口和一个出水口，你试图通过它泵入防腐剂，泵出一个，并尽可能地清理掉所有东西，以便尸体通常能保存大约一周。现代防腐也不是为了永久保存的，别让任何人告诉你相反的话。
They they quickly began to realize, like, this is not really a safe way to do this. Let's try something different. And there have been many different styles of embalming, not only throughout history, but even in modern embalming. There were, I think, a couple of different takes on how you could do this until kind of the modern method of arterial embalming where you basically have an end point and an exit point and you're trying to pump in embalming through it, pump out one, and clear out everything as much as possible so the body is preserved for generally about a week. Modern embalming is not meant to be permanent either, and don't let anyone tell you otherwise.
一周？我不知道。这太短了。是的，是的，不，确实如此。托马斯·霍姆斯（Thomas Holmes）。就是他。他被认为是现代防腐之父。是的，他是南北战争早期开始建立防腐帐篷并提供防腐服务的人之一。关于特别无良的防腐师，也有一些争议，他们会说：“嘿，我给你儿子防腐了。在你付清费用之前，我不放遗体。”而家属则表示：“我们没付钱。我们没让你给他防腐。”
A week? I didn't know. That's very short. Yes, yeah, no, it is. Thomas Holmes. That was him. That was considered the father of modern embalming. And yeah, he was one of the early people in the Civil War who started setting up their embalming tents and offering to embalm people. There were also some controversies about particularly unscrupulous embalmers that would be like, hey, I embalmed your son. I'm not releasing the body until you pay me the fee. And the family being, we didn't pay. We didn't want you to embalm them.
“我们会改天来收回遗骸的。”在某个时刻，事情变得有点恶劣。但，是的，现代防腐其实并不是为了保存超过一周。现在，如果防腐处理更强力的话——因为他们可以改变福尔马林与水的比例，如果尸体需要运送到全国各地——他们通常会进行
We will come collect the remains another time. It got a little nasty at a certain point. But yeah, modern embalming is not really meant to last more than a week. Now, if it's stronger embalming, because they can change the ratios of formalin to water and if the body needs to be shipped across the country, they'll typically do
更强力的防腐，但也有这样的例子：当由于某种原因必须掘出一具尸体时，他们发现，哦，其实这次防腐效果相当持久。虽然并非总是如此，但有时他们会发现，是的，让我想想，我知道有一个，我知道那是……并非总是如此，但有时他们会发现，是的。
stronger embalming, but there are examples of when a body has had to be exhumed for one reason or another, they've discovered like, oh, this embalming took pretty hard, actually. It's not always the case, but sometimes they will find like, yeah, let's see, I know there was a, I know that one was It's not always the case, but sometimes they will find like, yeah.
让我想想。我知道有一个，我知道那个是，这是另一个我得去查查的东西。但，是的，有几个，有几个例子表明，他们，他们，呃，特别是像谋杀案调查，比如，呃，掘开某人的棺材盖，然后说，我们可以做一个正常的尸检。这具尸体实际上保存得足够好，可以做到这一点。所以一般来说是一周，但并不总是这样。爱丽丝，你在你的执业中看到过关于死亡的精神或心理角色吗？你知道的，卡尼讨论的是实际的生存部分，但我不知道。你有什么想法吗？我的意思是，这种并置
Let's see. I know there was a, I know that one was, that's another one I got to go look up. But yeah, there's been several, there's been several examples of where they, they, they, uh, particularly like murder investigations, like, uh, exhume someone popped up to the casket and be like, we can do a normal autopsy. Like this, this body is actually well preserved enough for that. So that's as a rule a week, but not always. Alice, do you have anything about the spiritual or psychological role of death you see in your practice? You know, currently it's kind of the practical existential part of this, but I don't know. Do you have any thoughts? I mean, the juxtaposition
介于死亡在宗教和心理学中所扮演的角色（我们对此进行了消毒处理）与所发生事情的现实之间，只是相当有趣。我想深入探讨这一点会是一次很好的讨论。是的。我的执业经验里没有什么现成的想法。你刚才让我想到的其中一件事是，呃，我听说过，或者印度有一位古鲁（大师），他谈到身体需要13天才能让所有的细胞……抱歉，如果他想说的话他很好，欢迎他发言。维奥莱特有时会插话。有时需要……但据称需要13天所有的细胞才会死亡。所以他们不想在13天之前埋葬尸体，因为他们仍然认为灵魂还在体内。但我不是很确定。我不知道。
between kind of the role death plays in religion and psychology that we kind of sanitize and then just the realities of what happens are just kind of interesting. I thought sitting with that would make for a neat discussion. Yeah. Nothing off the top of my head from my practice. One thing you were making me think about is um i had heard or there's a guru in india who talks about how the body takes it takes 13 days for all of herself sorry he's fine if he wants to say he's welcome to say violet will pop in sometimes Sometimes it takes, but supposedly it takes 13 days for all of the cells to die. And so they don't want to bury the bodies before it's been 13 days because they still see it as the spirit still there in the body. But I'm not sure. I don't know.
我的意思是，我认为，你知道，有很多古代科学，其实最终证明了——如果我们现在去研究它——其实相当准确，但我不知道那有多大程度是真的。或者许多哀悼期，犹太教的不同派别也有这些，我的意思是，其中很多也起到了一种实际的作用，即前科学医学，你并不总是能判断一个人是否死了，你知道，有些情况下可能会发生。事实上，在那个时代，活埋曾经是一种风险，因为在维多利亚时代，对于如何真正判断一个人是否死亡的现代理解是非常不确定的，他们实际上开发了
I mean, I think, you know know there's a lot of ancient science that actually ends up being you know if we studied it now it's actually pretty accurate but i'm not sure how how true that is or a lot of the grieving periods like a different sex of judaism have those too i mean a lot of it served kind of a practical role too of that you know pre-scientific medicine you don't you couldn't always tell if somebody was dead you know there are some conditions that can be premature burial was actually a risk at one time uh because he had the modern understanding of how to actually determine whether someone was dead or not was was very shaky during the victorian era they actually developed
早期的复苏工具，用以让溺水的人复苏。问题是，它们并没有立刻流行起来，因为这种“你可能看起来死了但其实没死”的想法把人们吓坏了。这对某些人来说是一场噩梦。这就是为什么你在19世纪末的德国看到了“等待太平间”的出现，这基本上是这些大型太平间，你把你的家庭成员放在那里，让他们有效地开始
early resuscitation kits ways to revive people people from them being drowned. And the thing is, they didn't take off immediately because that idea freaked people out so much that you could appear dead and not be dead. That was a nightmare for some people. That's why you saw the advent in Germany towards the end of the 1800s of waiting mortuaries, which were basically these big mortuaries that you left your family member out to effectively begin
分解。一旦这些迹象出现，你就可以安全地埋葬他们了。不用太久。情况也是一样的。当时有这样的技术，比如你可以把棺材埋入地下，并在上面安装一个铃铛，如果尸体抽搐，就像，
decomposing. Once those signs appeared, you could safely bury them. Not too long. And it's the same thing. There was technology like coffins that you could bury and have a bell set up above them where if the body twitched, like,
哦，他们还活着，它就会摇铃。虽然人们有时会谈论这个，但它其实并不是铃铛的最初用途。还有那种弹簧加载的……在此处插入剪辑。对，在此处插入剪辑。没关系，因为我在那儿很安全。没关系，因为我在那儿很安全。但，是的，在很长一段时间里，这都是一种真实的恐惧，
oh, they're alive, it'll ring the bell. Not actually the original safe of the bell, even though people sometimes talk about that. There was also, like, spring-loaded... Insert clip here. Yeah, insert clip here. It's alright Cause I'm safe out of It's alright Cause I'm safe out of there But yeah, that was a true fear for a long time
直到我们能够建立更现代的医学方法来验证一个人是否死亡。是的，人们非常害怕活埋的概念。老实说，我现在还是很怕。这太可怕了。
until we were able to establish more modern medical methods of verifying someone is dead. Yeah, people were very scared of the concept of being buried alive. I still am, to be honest. It is terrifying. That's
绝对令人毛骨悚然。美国历史上有一些著名的人物。我想华盛顿曾说：在我下葬前把我的遗体放四天。这种例子有很多。我不做大量的催眠暗示和引导想象。这不是大多数人需要的，但那些我做过的人，这是一个相当
absolutely horrifying. There's famous individuals in American history. I think Washington said, leave out my body for four days before burying me. There are multiple examples of that sort of thing. I don't do a ton of hypnotic suggestion and guided imagery. It's not what most people need, but the people that I have done it with, that is a pretty
反复出现的意象：他们觉得自己被活埋了，就像被关在一个盒子里，他们需要打破它，不知怎么地逃出去并投入到生活中。我觉得这个话题的出现挺有趣的。是的，那确实是，呃，你……这有点像是一个转折，但，呃，你问过在我的实践中我有什么经验，当我们在谈论小孩子以及他们如何看待死亡时，有些东西突然闯入我的脑海。我记得小孩子们谈论死亡是非常迷人的。有一个，有一个，可能大约四岁的小男孩来过，他的父母把他带了进来。我记不清原因了。甚至可能是法院下令的事情，但他的父母带他来做评估。我通常不跟那么小的孩子工作。所以
reoccurring image that they feel like they are buried, like they are in a box and they need to break through and somehow get out and engage with their life i think it's kind of interesting that's come up yeah that is yeah um you it's just this is kind of a pivot but um you had asked about in in my practice what experience i have and i was something just popped in my head when we were talking about children and how they see death. I remember that little children talking about death is, is very fascinating. There was a, there was a, maybe like a four-year-old little boy who was coming at, his parents had brought him in. I can't remember what it was. It might've even been a court ordered thing, but his parents brought him in for assessment. I don't usually work with kids that little. So
单独而言，我通常会和整个家庭一起工作，但当时只有我和他。所以我试图，你知道的，做一些艺术治疗，然后他说了些关于他说话的事。他说：“哦，我的朋友，你知道的，我在外面玩的时候会和我的朋友马特说话。”我就说：“哦，那是好事。那是谁？是谁？”然后，
by themselves, I would work with them generally with a family, but it was just me and him. And so I was trying to, you know, do some art therapy and, and he said something about how he talks. He said, Oh, my friend, you know, I talked to my friend, Matt, when I play outside. And I was like, Oh, that's nice. Is that who is that? And, and he said, he's a bird. And I was, and I was like, Oh, okay. And, you know, got some, you know, talk to him about the bird that he talks to outside, who's a cardinal. And then I brought this up to his parents and they said, wait, who? And whatever the name was, it was specific enough that they were like, that's somebody who was our neighbor, who's friends with our son, who got killed in a car crash a few months ago. And they were like, we didn't even know that he knew that that had happened like it wasn't somebody that they thought you know it wasn't somebody that they the family had been talking about having passed away and um but he knew somehow he picked up he picked up on some kind of energy that this yeah you know just the way adults avoid something i think a lot of times
他说：“他是一只鸟。”然后我，然后我就说：“哦，好吧。”然后，你知道的，跟他聊了聊他在外面说话的那只鸟，是一只红衣凤头鸟。然后我把这件事提给了他的父母，他们说：“等等，是谁？”无论那个名字是什么，它足够具体，以至于他们觉得：“那是我们的一个邻居，是我们儿子的朋友，几个月前在车祸中丧生了。”他们说：“我们甚至不知道他知道那件事发生过”，这并不是一个他们以为你知道的、家族一直在谈论已经去世的人，但是，呃，他知道了，他不知怎么地捕捉到了一种能量，这……是的，你知道的，成年人回避某事的方式，我认为很多时候
gives kids information yeah yeah um i think that's and i i'll have people who've had like very like spiritual experiences like that where they've seen loved ones who pass on and and things like that and kind of but people don't want to tell you that stuff like i i would guess you think they think the therapist is uncomfortable with it or i think they think the therapist is going to think they're crazy, which is a no, no word. But I think I think there's this sense of because I would occasionally get someone who this would sort of come up like maybe they had what they felt like they were premonitions about things and they wouldn't they it was it was like they really didn't want to crack into talking about that until i took until i normalized it for them like experiences of loved ones after deaths but yeah it's something that people do not want to
会给孩子们提供信息。是的，是的，呃，我认为那是……而且我会有一些有过非常类似精神体验的人，他们见过去世的挚爱之类的事情，并且倾向于……但人们不想告诉你这些东西——我猜你会认为他们觉得治疗师对此会感到不自在，或者我认为他们觉得治疗师会认为他们疯了，这是一个绝对不能说出的词。但我认为，我认为有一种感觉，因为我偶尔会遇到这样的人，这种情况会冒出来，就好像他们感觉自己对事情有预感一样，而他们不会……这就像他们真的不想开始谈论这个，直到我接受并为他们将这些体验（比如死后与挚爱的经历）正常化。但，是的，这是人们极力想要避免谈论的事情。
talk about with therapists i think i mean unless you're really put yourself out there as a death um kind of death and dying expert but i don't know if is there is there such a thing you know i mean you can probably find researchers that technically fill that that niche but yeah i don't know if there's there's anyone i don't know how much like actual serious study has been put into i mean i'm sure it's it's scattered about but not being kind of like centralized study of this sort of it's they go back to death in a lot of different um uh scientific soft sciences anthropology sociology a ton like um one of the ways that when they're looking at evolution and they're like when is the brain that is developing and the evolving human not an animal you know when is there some kind of awareness of something else? And the
和治疗师聊聊，我的意思是，除非你真的把自己包装成死亡，嗯，某种死亡和临终专家，但我不知道是否有这种存在，你知道我的意思，你大概能找到技术上填补这个空白的研究人员，但，是的，我不知道是否真的有人，我不知道有多少真正严肃的研究投入到——我的意思是，我确信它们是零星分布的，但并没有进行这种集中式的研究。人类对死亡的追溯其实存在于许多不同的科学、软科学中，比如人类学、社会学，有大量的研究，就像，嗯，其中一个例子是，当他们研究进化时，他们会问：发展中的大脑和进化的智人，在什么时候才不再是一只动物？你知道，在什么时候，才会对某种非自身的事物产生意识？而他们
thing that they look for is when do we start to bury people or do something? We didn't have to bury them. When grandma just falls over and everyone keeps walking on to eat the apple, that's not human in our mind. And then it is human when we stop and boot and wink or some kind of ritual that recognizes this. That's what they're looking for a ton of the time. And I don't know, we still have those rituals. You know, it was the beginning of our humanity. Robert Pogue Harrison, who I'd love to have on here, but he's not interested in my email so far.
寻找的事物就是，我们从什么时候开始埋葬人类或者做点什么的？我们其实不一定非得把他们埋了。当奶奶突然倒下，而每个人都继续走过去吃苹果时，在我们的脑海里，那还称不上是真正的人类。而当我们在某个时刻停下来，或者进行某种仪式来承认这一点的发生，那才真正体现了人性。很多时候，他们寻找的就是这个。而且我不知道，我们至今仍然保留着那些仪式。你知道，那是我们人性的开端。罗伯特·波格·哈里森，我很乐意请他来这里，但他到现在对我的电子邮件一点兴趣也没有。
But he wrote The Dominion of the Dead. And one of the points he makes in there is that social animals are the most vocal when something dies. And so when you're looking at when did we have kind of the dead. And one of the points he makes in there is that social animals are the most vocal when something dies. And so when you're looking at, when did we have kind of the synesthetic connection between sound and meaning? When did we say like, Oh wait,
但他写过《死者的统治》。他在书中提出的观点之一是，社会性动物在有同类死亡时反应最强烈。所以，当你探究我们究竟是什么时候开始关注死者的。他在书中提出的观点之一是，社会性动物在有同类死亡时反应最强烈。所以，当你探究，我们究竟是什么时候开始拥有声音和意义之间的这种联觉联系的？我们在什么时候开始说，哦等等，
my mouth can make these noises, but I could fit little meanings in here. I could make this into a code, you know, differentiating between different things. It probably was around death because you have animals like an animal dies. The lion mom roars, you know, certain vocalization dies the lion mom roars you know certain vocalization for the baby and you know and maybe calling it to come back or whatever you know when the people are around in their you know mourning slowly these noises start to mean different things
我的嘴能发出这些声音，但我可以在这里面塞进一些小小的意义。我可以把这变成一种密码，你知道的，用来区分不同的事物。这很可能就发生在死亡周围，因为你会发现这样的动物现象：当一只动物死去了，母狮会发出怒吼，你知道，特定的发音——当小动物死去了，母狮会发出怒吼，你知道，为了宝宝发出特定的发音，你知道的，也许是呼唤它回来什么的，你知道当人们聚在一起，在他们的悲伤中，你知道，慢慢地哀悼，这些声音开始有了不同的含义
and yeah and particularly throughout human history there's been tradition of like vocal mourning not not not necessarily in... Rome had paid mourners. You had to pay people to scream. The ancient Egyptians paid mourners of Irish keening. Like, yeah, there's lots of ways that people have turned their grief into these very loud vocal expressions,
是的，特别是在整个人类历史中，一直有一种声乐哀悼的传统，并非，不一定是在……古罗马曾有付费哭丧人。你得花钱请人尖叫。古埃及人也请过哭丧人，还有爱尔兰的哭丧传统。就像，是的，人们有很多种方法将悲伤转化为这种非常响亮的有声表达，
which is not as common, particularly I think the modern West, but I mean, you still see it. And it certainly is something that has occurred in the past. I think, I mean, it might be Alan Wolfe. I don't know if you, do you know him, Joel? He's an expert in grief and loss. And, oh, she, well, I was going to say, he talks,
这其实并不是那么常见，尤其是在我看来现代西方世界，不过，我的意思是，你仍然能看到它。而且这绝对是过去曾发生过的事情。我想，我的意思是，那个人可能是艾伦·沃尔夫。我不知道你，乔尔，你认识他吗？他是悲伤和失落领域的专家。哦，她，好吧，我本来想说，他谈论的是，
I just lost my point that I was going to say, what did you. I was talking about burial, Kearney. Yeah. More morning. Oh yeah. Yeah.
我刚才忘了我正要说的话，你刚才说什么来着。我刚才在谈论土葬，卡尼。是的。更多的哀悼。哦，对了。是的。
Grieving grief and loss in that way. Vocal grieving. That, that it's people adjust way more to have better adjustment to death death in the psychological world and how in kind of modern society we've oh we do funerals but i mean modern western society we do funerals but um we've really stripped away a lot of the ritual you know we don't and in jewish funerals you know you have several days of sh ritual, you know, we don't, and in Jewish funerals, you know, you have several days of Shiva that you sit and more if it's depending on who the person was and what the role is and where people come and gather at the house. And, and it's like an open house for people to come grieve and come by.
以这种方式哀悼悲伤和失落。有声的哀悼。那种，人们对死亡有更好的适应方式——在心理学领域，人们如何看待现代社会中，哦，我们确实会办葬礼，但我的意思是，现代西方社会我们虽然会办葬礼，但是，嗯，我们真的剥夺了很多仪式感，你知道，我们不会，而在犹太人的葬礼中，你知道，你有好几天的西瓦（Shiva）仪式，你知道，我们不会，而在犹太人的葬礼中，你知道，你有好几天的时间坐在那里哀悼，如果根据逝者的身份、角色以及人们聚集在房子的哪个地方而定。而且，这就好像是一个开放日，让大家来哀悼并顺道拜访。
And people in Jewish faith do a lot better with death than in other, than in other cultures, just because of these kind of traditions and rituals that actually... Because it's not only a transition. We talk about whatever we think about the spirituality of death, but like a transition from being alive to not being here anymore whatever that transition is um but um well it's also kind of a death of the participant in the ritual too you know if my parents die that means that i'm something different part of me has died and i'm in a new role you know so it is a transition on two levels yeah yeah that yeah that transition and, exactly. Kind of the transition of the family, like letting the person go and everyone getting to have the moment of kind of reckoning of, you know, coming over to the house and they're not there anymore. for me after my grandmother passed away, who is my very closest relative. And I was at her house when, you know, she was in the hospital. It was just kind of out of the blue. So everything in the house was, it wasn't like a sick person's house. It was all, you know, where I usually
犹太信仰的人比其他文化的人更能应对死亡，仅仅因为这些传统的仪式实际上……因为这不仅是一个转变。无论我们怎么看待死亡的精神内涵，但就像是一个从活着到不复存在的转变，无论那种转变是什么，嗯，但是，嗯，其实它也算是参与仪式者的某种“死亡”，你知道的，如果我的父母去世了，那就意味着我变成了某种不同的人，我的一部分已经死去，而我进入了一个新的角色，你知道，所以在两个层面上这都是一种转变，是的，是的，那个转变，没错。某种程度上说，这是家庭的转变，就像是放手让逝者离开，每个人都有机会迎来这样一个清算时刻，你知道的，来到房子里，而他们却已经不在了。对我来说，是在我外婆去世之后，她是我最亲近的亲人。当她，你知道的，还在医院时，我正在她家里。那一切来得很突然。所以房子里的所有东西，它并不像是一个病人的家。那一切都是，你知道的，我通常
would have spent the night and, and stuff. And so I was still spending, you know, I'd gone up to see her and was spending the night in my bed where I would usually stay. And then there were people at the house and it sort of felt, it was very comforting to be able to be there in her house and like where I, where is one of the most comforting places to me, but be in that environment and really, yeah, kind of, I mean, it just, those types of experiences can be, can be stealing. Yeah. Well, I think the good points made there is like when, when the transition of death becomes almost entirely transactional, which it is in, in the modern American funeral industry
会过夜的地方，诸如此类的。所以我仍然在花时间，你知道的，我去看望过她，并且在我的床上过夜，也就是我通常呆的地方。然后屋子里有很多人，那种感觉，能待在她的家里，以及待在对我而言最感安慰的地方之一，并且置身于那种环境中，真的，是的，那种体验，我的意思是，这类经历真的可以起到安抚作用。是的。嗯，我认为那里提出了一个很好的观点，就像当，死亡的转变变得几乎完全是交易性的，在现代美国殡葬业中确实如此，
in particular, like, yeah, that strips out all the ritualism. It feels very hollow when you're just paying some dude in a bad suit to put on, like, just that CD of very obnoxious, sad, twinkly piano music and shine a pink light on your relative. Like, yeah, that feels incredibly hollow and empty. Like, I can imagine that, yeah, people can walk away from funerals,
特别是，是的，这剥夺了所有的仪式感。当你只是付钱给一个穿得不合身的西装的家伙，让他放一张那种非常讨厌的、悲伤的、闪烁的钢琴曲CD，并用粉红色的灯光照射你的亲人时，感觉非常空洞。是的，这感觉真是难以置信的空洞和虚无。就像，我可以想象，是的，人们会从葬礼上离开，
like feeling very unfulfilled because of that. How old? Oh, I'm sorry. Well, that was like when, when my grandmother passed away, we actually very deliberately like, we actually avoided almost all the traps in the funeral. I was the only one that saw her in the casket. casket not just because i hadn't seen her when she passed um after that we did a
因为这一点而感到非常不满足。多大？哦，我很抱歉。好吧，就像当，当我外婆去世时，我们实际上非常刻意地，我们实际上避去了葬礼上的几乎所有陷阱。我是唯一一个在棺材里看到她的人。棺材里，不仅仅是因为在她去世后我没见过她——在那之后我们举办了
crypt side service like she was already uh she was already in the crypt put away like we just we pulled up photos and just had a good reminiscing session and that was that felt really really good because yeah i think it is i think honestly the healthiest way to deal with death is having the family involved. Like, as much as you can take care of your disease, rather than not hand it off entirely to some other group of people, probably the better you're going to feel psychologically at the end, I would think. Alice, how old did you say the child was that was talking to the cardinal that you had? Four. Four, yeah. yeah alice how old did you say the child was that was talking to the cardinal that you had four four yeah um there's a part in yalom where he gets a little bit more speculative
墓穴边的追悼仪式，就像她已经——她已经被放进墓穴安顿好了，我们只是翻出了照片，好好地回忆了一番，那感觉真的很棒，因为，是的，我觉得，老实说，处理死亡最健康的方式就是让家人参与进来。就像，只要你能尽可能地照顾好你的亲人，而不是完全把它交托给其他人，你最终在心理上可能会感觉越好，我是这么想的。爱尔塔，你刚才说那个和红衣主教说话的孩子多大了？四岁。四岁，对。是的，爱尔塔，你刚才说那个和红衣主教说话的孩子多大了？四岁，四岁，是的，嗯，欧文·亚隆的书里有一个部分，他进行了更多的推测，
and existential therapy i think it's kind of interesting but he he kind of speculates that uh ed's uh i don't know the age range but he says basically at two they know what death is and they're fine with it and then by four they kind of start not being able to accept it anymore and that by like six or seven they have a very adult-like almost religious defense mechanism against the reality of death and he's talking about how a lot of two-year-olds and things like they like kind of know something's wrong like three four they'll see a bird that dies in the yard as example he gives them they're like yelling at the parent to put it back in the nest or to make it talk um and they have this kind of they're kind of enamored with it but then if you come back
还有存在主义疗法，我觉得这挺有意思的，但他，他有点推测说，呃，爱德华的，我不知道年龄范围，但他基本上说，在两岁时他们就知道什么是死亡了，他们对此觉得没问题，然后到了四岁左右，他们开始不再能够接受这一点，而到了六岁或七岁左右，他们就有了非常成人化的、几乎是宗教性质的防御机制来对抗死亡的现实，他在谈论很多两岁的孩子之类的时候，他们似乎有点知道有些不对劲，三四岁时，他们会在院子里看到一只死去的鸟，这是他给出的例子，他们会对父母大喊大叫，要求把它放回巢穴里，或者让它说话，
to the same kids and you talk about that by the time they're six seven then they have like some sort of uh you know defense mechanism against death where they're like no he went to another world and there's this world or like i actually have magic so i can see that but there's something that the brain creates to help them understand this thing that they can kind of accept when they're younger, which is kind of an interesting part about Yalom. I wish he said more about that. It's just two pages in there. But it's one of the more interesting kind of speculations that he makes. Yeah.
他们对这种现象有些着迷，但如果你回过头来
Do you think some of that is them beginning to kind of internalize how other people around them are reacting or he doesn't say I would say that I mean I remember I worked with kids in my first show about a college like a group and there was like someone's dad died and there were parents who were
你认为其中有些原因是他们开始内化周围其他人如何反应，还是他没说？我不会这么说，我的意思是——我记得我在大学的第一个项目里和孩子们一起工作过，有一个群体，其中某个人的爸爸去世了，有些家长
like it wasn't like a formal funeral either it was like a big kind of celebration of life. Everybody dressed casually, like, you know, music and whatever. But they were like stopping their kids from going who were like sixth grade, seventh grade. I mean, not really young. And they were like, well, they're just so young. I don't want them to be around that. And I was like, you know, no, this is normal.
这甚至不像是一个正式的葬礼，而是一场盛大的生命庆典。每个人都穿便服，你知道，有音乐什么的。但他们却在阻止他们的孩子前往，那些孩子已经上六年级、七年级了。我的意思是，并不是真的很小。他们却说，哦，他们太小了。我不想让他们接触那种事。而我说，你知道，不，这是正常的。
This is natural. Like the lesson that you're teaching here is not good. You know, this fear does not go away away this thing does not normalize itself um and i think like we do have a culture that just hides death away from children from everybody and we have this sort of you know probably fueled by you know uh capital this like need to sell you something and we pretend to be young forever and ever and then you having done some jerry psych and some like hospice social work people don't know how to die you know they never maybe we know intellectually that we do but we don't ever have any tools to approach that phase
这是自然的。你在这里教给他们的这个教训并不好。你知道，这种恐惧并没有消失，这种事情并没有让自己正常化，嗯，我觉得我们的文化确实把死亡对儿童、对所有人都隐藏起来了，我们拥有这种，你知道的，可能是由资本主义所助长的，这种向你兜售东西的需求，我们假装自己永远永远年轻，然后，在你做了一些老年精神病学和一些临终关怀社会工作之后，人们不知道如何去死，你知道，他们可能在理智上知道我们终究会死，但我们从来没有任何工具来接近生命的那个阶段，
of life and it is it is a part of life um i don't know i mean do you see that else the kind of like just fear of death that we have here that it's not something that i don't think is is even normal or human honestly you know it's kind of contra yeah um i've noticed this with my my son who's about kindergarten who's in kindergarten and um yeah there was my dad doesn't fish but for some reason he was like i've got to take hank fishing it's like i guess he turned into a grandfather and it's like okay i never learned to fish i've got to figure this out um but so we go to the go to the lake with a fishing pole and so it turns out my dad's not going to actually he's not actually into it because it like because he's an emergency room physician.
它是，它确实是生命的一部分——我不知道，我的意思是，你在爱尔塔身上看到了吗？那种我们这里存在的对死亡的恐惧，这甚至不是正常或人性应有的表现，老实说，你知道，这有点违背……是的，嗯，我从我儿子身上注意到了这一点，他大约上幼儿园，正在上幼儿园，而且，嗯，我爸爸不会钓鱼，但出于某种原因，他好像说：“我必须带汉克去钓鱼”，就像他突然有了当爷爷的心态，然后觉得，好吧，我从来没学过钓鱼，我得弄清楚这个。但随后我们带着钓竿去了湖边，结果发现我爸爸其实并不怎么想钓鱼，因为他觉得，因为他是一名急诊室医生。
And then it's all of a sudden, like he, he's, he's saying, well, it kind of makes me sad to catch the fish. And even when you're, and he, he got really, my father got really sad about, you know, a fish that he had caught, like a tiny, a little fish that he had caught and then couldn't get the hook out right. And didn't know what, and, you know, and then my dad didn't want to really fish anymore. And I thought that was, it was really interesting, but my son, I'm not sure if he even really processed that that was happening, but there were some other kids there showing him how to do the fishing, fishing rod. And, um, and and there was a there was a little fish that they ended up it was like this group of children trying to revive this fish on the dock and like the three of them like it was it was like 30 minutes of them like trying to resuscitate this fish and they got it i think they got it to like flap around again like and then and so they
然后突然之间，他说，这让他对钓鱼感到有些难过。甚至当你在钓鱼时，他——我的父亲对一条他钓上来的鱼感到非常难过，那是一条他钓上来的极小的鱼，结果钩子没能好好取下来。不知道该怎么办，你知道，然后我爸爸就不太想继续钓鱼了。我觉得这真的很有意思，但我儿子，我不确定他是否真的意识到了正在发生的事情，但那里还有其他一些孩子在向他展示如何使用钓鱼竿，然后，嗯，还有一条小鱼，他们最后，这是一群孩子试图在码头上救活这条鱼，他们三个就像是花了大约30分钟试图让这条鱼复活，我觉得他们确实让它再次扑腾起来了——然后，所以他们
were thinking okay we're gonna we're really gonna bring it back to life but it was this whole thing where it's and then my dad and I were kind of pacing around awkwardly like not really you know not not wanting to say no it's really not coming back to life um because I mean you just feel you feel bad saying that when it's like kid, but then it was like, well, the lesson teaches itself because he, you know, eventually he's like, okay, well, it's not going to work. Let's go. Yeah. Yeah. But yeah, but I, I, and I, something else you're making me think I'm, I remember, you know, adults trying to hide death. And so there were several times where I was like on a trip or something when I was young,
当时在想，好吧，我们要把它真正地救活，但整个过程就是这样，然后我和我爸爸就尴尬地在周围踱步，并没有真正地，你知道，不想说“不，它真的活不过来了”——因为我的意思是，当对象是个孩子时，说这种话你会觉得很内疚，但随后就变成了，好吧，这个教训会自己显现出来，因为他，你知道，最终他会说，“好吧，看来行不通了。我们走吧。”是的。是的。但是，是的，而且，我，你让我想起了另一件事，我记得，你知道，成年人们试图掩盖死亡。所以有几次当我年轻的时候去旅行什么的，
and there would be somebody who passed away. And they didn't tell, you know, they didn't want to tell me because I was out of town. And then it was like the funeral had happened and everything happened while I was, while I wasn't there. And nobody let me me know or one time I was on college and a great aunt died and I didn't find out until like a couple weeks later and I was I was so mad that it was like this even you know even as like a 20 year old it felt like it feels like the people in older generations were still trying to like brush things under the rug and yeah very my yeah there's a lot of discomfort with death and anglo-american families for sure like i know stephen jenkins is a palliative care counselor that's written some books he's uh interesting um but he always talks about the us not being
会有人去世。而他们没有告诉，你知道，他们不想告诉我，因为我当时不在镇上。然后就变成了葬礼已经举行过了，所有事情都在我不在的时候发生了。没有人通知我，或者有一次我在上大学时，一位远房阿姨去世了，我直到几周后才知道，我当时气得要命，甚至在作为20岁的人的时候，也觉得老一辈的人仍然试图把事情掩盖起来，而且，是的，非常……我的，是的，在英美家庭中，对死亡肯定有很多不适感——我知道史蒂芬·詹金斯是一位写过一些书的姑息治疗顾问，他挺有意思的——但他总是谈到美国人对死亡感到不
comfortable with death and then the cultural problems and vulnerabilities that we have i mean kearney started talking about people getting basically calmed uh you know when they're grieving a loved one i mean there's a lot of vulnerability that americans have about that that i think we don't notice um i mean even like makeup is like you'll be 10 years younger you'll last forever you know it's like they don't just start selling you mortuary makeup when you're dead i mean they start when you're 12. they um that was actually that also something with the industry if they had to legally they had to stop claiming that embalming could preserve you forever because they absolutely tried to claim that at first and with with the arsenic i mean yeah yeah you also became very toxic but i mean but but yeah it's like
适应，以及我们所拥有的文化问题和脆弱性。我的意思是，卡尼开始谈到人们在哀悼亲人时基本上被哄骗的情况——我的意思是，美国人在这方面有很多脆弱性，我认为我们没有注意到这一点——我的意思是，甚至像化妆品也是如此——你会年轻10岁，你会永远保持青春，你知道，这就好比他们并不是等你死了才开始向你兜售太平间用的化妆品，我的意思是他们从你12岁就开始了。他们，嗯，实际上这也是该行业的一个特点，如果他们必须在法律上停止宣称防腐处理能让你永远保存，因为他们一开始绝对试图宣称这一点，而且还加上了砷——我的意思是，是的，是的，你也会变得非常有毒，但我的意思是——但，是的，这就好像
that's much like any eventually yeah much like like any, you know, industry for profit. Like, yeah, they're going to sell you the rosiest possible picture they can. You know, they're not going to tell you that, like, yeah, this isn't going to last forever. And it's going to get, it's probably going to get a little nasty. Yeah. Well, and I think, I mean,'s the the birth of buddhism right the earliest thing that we can tell that hinduism is splitting off and doing something kind of different is that the hindu uh a lot of the religious figures just start hanging out in
最终，是的，就像任何谋利行业一样。就像，是的，他们会向你兜售尽可能美好的画面。你知道，他们不会告诉你，比如，是的，这不会永远持续下去。而且事情可能会变得有点糟糕。是的。嗯，而且我认为，这就是佛教的诞生，对吧？我们能看出的印度教分裂并做出一件完全不同的事情的最早迹象是，印度教的许多宗教人物开始在
torno pits looking at bodies and it's kind of like you know the glittering dharma and moksha and temple and you know pathway to god through the self was maybe a little bit avoidant and then they start being like hey hey, we die. Or is this really real? You know, whatever. They're psychically chewing on, you know, Buddhism goes a different direction than Hinduism does to handle an anxiety that the culture is maybe not sitting with. I mean, yeah.
火葬场周围闲逛，看着尸体，这就像是，你知道的，璀璨的正法（Dharma）、解脱（Moksha）、寺庙和（你知道的）通过自我通往神的道路可能有点逃避现实，然后他们开始说：“嘿，嘿，我们会死。这真的是真实的吗？”你知道，无论如何。他们在心理上咀嚼着（这种焦虑），佛教走向了与印度教不同的方向，以应对一种文化可能并未真正面对的焦虑。我的意思是，是的。
Y'all have any like ideas about how good death could be? I'm more, you know, Courtney knows a lot about religious practices around the world, like a more natural or sustainable or psychologically healthy you know process or there is there other examples out there um i think um i mean i really think it would be cool if people started leaning into kind of like mortuary gardens like places where you could just naturally vary people and maybe you know maybe you could have a small marker but also it's like it's it's not just it's not a lawn like we have now it's actually you can see stuff like blooming and growing you know partially from the fact that yeah like yeah your loved one is going back to the environment at least for me that would make me very content
你们对什么是好的死亡有什么看法吗？我更倾向于，（你知道，柯尼对世界各地的宗教习俗了解很多），比如一种更自然、更可持续或心理上健康的流程，或者还有其他的例子吗？嗯，我真的觉得，如果人们开始倾向于某种墓葬花园，比如那些你可以自然地安葬人们的地方，或许，你知道的，你可以有一个小墓碑，但它同时也是——它不仅仅是一片我们现在见到的那种草坪，而是你实际上可以看到各种植物在盛开和生长，部分原因在于，是的，就像——是的，你爱的人正在回归大自然，至少对我来说，这会让我感到非常满足。
i'd love to i'd love to go like hey let hey, let's go take a hike through the gardens. Go see so-and-so real quick. You're going back anyway. Just how long do you want to put it off? Yeah. We are headed back into something that is not really an avoidable destination, no matter how much formaldehyde. I mean, it's just, in the end, we will eventually hit a point where it's like, look, we've got to start disposing of people in more efficient
我很乐意去说：“嘿，嘿，让我们去花园里徒步吧。顺便去看看某某。”反正你最终也是要回去的。你究竟想拖延多久呢？是的。我们正在走向一个无论注入多少甲醛都无法真正避开的终点。我的意思是，到头来，我们终究会达到这样一个地步：看吧，我们必须开始以更高效、更可持续的方式来处理遗体。
and sustainable ways. Alkaline hydrolysis is starting to get big, which I hope that they start implementing that as a greener method of doing cremations. The idea of it freaks people out to no end, but as soon as you kind of learn exactly what it does and what the end result is, it's barely any different from cremation.
碱性水解法（Alkaline hydrolysis）开始流行起来，我希望他们能开始将其作为一种更环保的火化方法来实施。这个想法让人们感到无比恐慌，但一旦你了解了它的确切工作原理和最终结果，它其实和火化几乎没有什么区别。
What do you think, Alice? Google is kind of auto-blurring it. What is the pyramid behind you on the wall? Is that a picture of a temple, a ziggurat, or is that like an artwork? I can't. No, it's not. It is a... Okay, temple, a ziggurat, or is that like an artwork? I can't. No, it's not. It is a, that one down. Okay, it's a mountain.
你觉得呢，爱尔塔？谷歌好像自动把那部分模糊处理了。你墙上的那个金字塔是什么？那是寺庙的照片、庙塔（ziggurat），还是某种艺术品？我看不清。不，不是。它是一个……好吧，寺庙、庙塔，还是某种艺术品？我看不清。不，不是。它是一个，那个下面。好吧，它是一座山。
Gotcha. That's a mountain with different pieces. It's not a pyramid. And a map of my dreamscape up there that I've been working on. Yeah, I love the idea of green cemeteries. I mean, it has to catch on at some point. I mean, and wasn't it true, Kearney, you probably would know this,
明白了。那是一座有着不同部分的群山。不是金字塔。上面是我一直在创作的梦境地图。是的，我喜欢绿色公墓的想法。我的意思是，它在某个时候必须流行起来。而且，卡尼，这不是真的吗，你可能知道这一点，
wasn't it true that cemeteries used to be where people would go out and picnic in the cemeteries and it was like a fun place that people would go with the family on the weekend. Yeah. That was, that was a big thing, particularly during the, the Victorian age. Because I mean, the big problem was urban cemeteries in places like London were just not sustainable. You could not, they, they were literally like,
难道不是真的吗，以前人们会去公墓野餐，公墓就像是一个周末可以和家人一起去玩的有趣地方？是的。那曾是一件大事，特别是在维多利亚时代。因为我的意思是，当时最大的问题是伦敦等地的城市公墓根本无法持续。你无法——它们简直就像是，
they were burying people on top of each other and running out of room. Like you would, you would go six inches down, hit a coffin, kind of thing. Not like, there was a reason that people thought that that urban cemeteries were you know gross nasty places because yeah when you have that many bodies in one place it doesn't matter if they're under the soil it's still gonna smell bad it's still gonna be like nasty so they they started a movement to try and do kind of these rural cemeteries, these like the one of the first big. I don't know what the first big necropolis was, but I know it was a member of the royal family got married to a commoner. So they were unable to be buried in the standard accommodation.
它们把人们层层叠叠地埋在一起，空间都不够用了。就像你往下挖六英寸，就能碰到一副棺材那种。并不是说——人们认为城市公墓是恶心肮脏的地方是有原因的，因为当你有那么多尸体在一个地方时，不管它们是不是埋在土里，它闻起来还是会很臭，感觉还是会很糟糕，所以他们发起了一场运动，试图建造这种乡村公墓，就像其中一个最早的大型墓地。我不知道第一个大型墓地是什么，但我知道那是皇室成员和一个平民结婚了。所以他们无法被埋葬在标准的墓地里。
So instead, they got a nice little tomb in one of these rural cemeteries. And that was kind of the thing that kicked it all off. As soon as one of the royal family did it, everyone was like, OK, I want my tomb now. And yeah, so they very much used to be like, yeah, places you could go out and picnic, places you could go for a walk. Modern cemeteries are generally not nearly as interesting, obviously. But yeah, that's what they initially started out, both as a method of figuring out what to do with urban cemeteries, but also it was just like, yeah, this is a nice green space we can enjoy.
相反，他们在其中一个乡村墓地里得到了一个不错的小陵墓。这就是这一切的开端。一旦皇室成员中有人这么做了，每个人都觉得：“好吧，现在我也想要我的陵墓了。”是的，所以它们在很大程度上曾经是那种你可以去野餐、可以去散步的地方。现代公墓通常远没有那么有趣，显而易见。但，是的，这正是它们最初的起点，既是一种弄清楚如何处理城市公墓的方法，也只是一种——是的，这是一个我们可以享受的美丽绿地。
This is a nice third space we can have. Yeah, even buttoned up repressive Victoria was a lot better at death than we are now. I mean, what was it? You ever seen those hair flowers? They would make your relatives hair into like decoration, like ornaments that you kept around your house. Oh yeah. Yeah.
这是一个我们可以拥有的美妙第三空间。是的，甚至连古板压抑的维多利亚时代在对待死亡上也比我们现在做得好得多。我的意思是，那是什么？你见过那些头发花吗？他们会把亲人的头发做成装饰品，比如放在你屋里当摆设。哦，是的。是的。
And the, the photography. There's a picture floating around of my grandfather's little brother who died when he was maybe two or something and there's a a death photo that we found in some albums somewhere and it's i don't know you know it's so it's so sad to me it really is see the photo of this beautiful little baby who's but that was such a thing i mean they were very comfortable getting up and close with death in those ways. Or memento mori hung around to the Victorian period.
还有摄影。有一张照片流传开来，是我祖父的小弟弟的照片，他大概两岁左右就去世了，我们在某个相册里找到了一张遗体照片，我不知道，你知道的，这让我感到非常难过，真的，看到这张可爱的小婴儿的照片，但他已经——那曾是一种风潮，我的意思是，他们非常习惯以那种方式近距离接触死亡。或者说“死者纪念”（Memento Mori）一直持续到了维多利亚时期。
I think it started medieval, maybe. Do you know that one, Kerney? Are you familiar with that? Yeah, memento mori. I mean, there's always been examples of memento mori going back as far as like the Romans. Do you remember the incident at Suwannee with the bone? No, I don't. Do you remember the incident at Swanee with the bone? No. You might have left before that, but somebody basically was doing work on a building or something, and they found bones. The police had to come and stuff.
我想它始于中世纪，也许吧。你知道那个吗，卡尼？你熟悉吗？是的，死者纪念。我的意思是，从罗马人时期开始，就一直有死者纪念的例子。你还记得在萨万尼（Suwanee）发生的骨头事件吗？不，我不记得。你还记得在萨万尼发生的骨头事件吗？不记得。你可能在那之前就离开了，但基本上有人在某栋建筑里施工什么的，然后他们发现了骨头。警察不得不赶来之类的事情。
It was just an office. I think it was the admissions office. Somebody found a femur on the keyboard that fell out of the ceiling. Human hair and bones yeah but then the police were like no this is you know hundreds of years old it's fine um and they think the best guess of it was it was somebody's memento mori that at one person at one point it had somehow made its way into the drop ceiling because you know so when he was old civil war academy some of that was still going on um but the memento mori tradition they basically uh usually a transition place when you graduated school or starting a job or what
那只是一间办公室。我想那是招生办公室。有人在键盘上发现了一根从天花板上掉下来的股骨。人类的头发和骨头，是的。但后来警察说：“不，这是几百年前的，没关系。”他们最好的猜测是，那是某人的死者纪念品，在某个时候，它不知怎么掉进了吊顶里，因为，你知道的，萨万尼曾经是一所南北战争时期的学院，有些那类习俗仍在延续。但死者纪念的传统，他们基本上，通常在你从学校毕业、开始工作或结婚等转折点时，
married whatever they'll just give you a bone and be like remember you die eventually so make it count that's yeah keep a little bone around that's what i'm gonna start doing a human bone not just yeah yeah now i'm gonna start like i'm gonna make sure i carry like just human vertebrae on me and when i meet people for the first time i'll give them one when i'm probably saying goodbye and just hey remember you're gonna die one day so you know you're up selling the mental morning i'm gonna get a whole skeleton on my back and give it a piggyback ride because i really want to make my life better i'm taking it everywhere i am going on shark tank with my new my new uh future Memento Mori. It's going to be a great thing.
就会给你一根骨头并说：“记住，你终究会死，所以让生命有意义吧。”那就是——随身带一根小骨头，这就是我打算开始做的。一根人类的骨头，而不只是——是的，现在我要开始——我要确保自己随身携带像人类脊椎骨一样的东西，当我第一次见到别人时，在道别的时候我会送他们一块，顺便说一句：“嘿，记住你总有一天会死，所以，你知道的。”你这是在推销“死者纪念”。我打算在背上背一整个骷髅，让它骑在我背上，因为我真的很想让我的生活变得更好，我把它带到我去的所有地方。我要带着我全新的未来“死者纪念”去《创智赢家》（Shark Tank）。这绝对会是一个绝佳的点子。
But yeah, Memento Mori have a history. I mean, the Romans had them. There's a famous example of a, it's not a fresco. It's a mosaic in Pompeii of a skeleton holding two wine jugs, like the dangers of drinking. And of course, Memento Mori got big boosts throughout history. Of course, the plague. It's the first anti-drugs ad. Yeah.
不过，是的，“死者纪念”确实有历史渊源。罗马人就有。庞贝古城有一个著名的例子，不是湿壁画，而是一个马赛克镶嵌画，画着一个骷髅拿着两个酒罐，象征着饮酒的危害。当然，“死者纪念”在历史上得到了大力的推广。当然，还有黑死病。这是第一个反毒品广告。是的。
How do you Latinize Nancy Reagan? What is that? I've actually, when I was in high school, I was fortunate enough... Regus Septimus. I was fortunate enough in high school to be able to take a Europe trip and go see in Switzerland. I went through a little town that had actual like play guard on its on some of its bridges. So seeing some of the, you know, the dance macabre scenes of dancing skeletons and stuff is very cool.
你怎么把南希·里根拉丁化？那是什么？我其实，当我在高中时，我很幸运……瑞格斯·塞普蒂姆斯（Regus Septimus）。我在高中时很幸运，能够参加一次欧洲旅行，去看看瑞士。我穿过了一个小镇，那里的一些桥上居然有真正的黑死病守卫。所以看到一些（你知道的）表现骷髅跳舞的“死亡之舞”（Danse Macabre）场景非常酷。
There was a little while during the Renaissance that cadaver tombs got very popular. It was like the chic thing was instead of showing yourself on top of your tomb in effigy, you would show the rotting version of yourself on top of your tomb in effigy. So they went through this very nice we kind of like the Dark Souls aesthetic and went hard into that
文艺复兴时期有一小段时间，尸体墓穴（cadaver tombs）变得非常流行。当时的时尚不是在墓碑顶端雕刻你生前的雕像，而是在墓碑顶端雕刻你腐烂的尸体形象。所以他们经历了一段非常美妙的时期——我们有点喜欢这种“黑暗之魂”的美学，并在一段时间内对此进行了深入挖掘。
for a little while. I would love to see something like that make a comeback. My God, our death rituals are so sterile. I want to see, like, start slapping some, like, barber-leaf skull on stuff again. Yeah, is the Party City, you know, skeleton, is that really the height of what we should do?
我很乐意看到类似的东西卷土重来。天哪，我们的死亡仪式太缺乏生气了。我想看到，比如，重新在一些东西上贴上像理发店那种骷髅标志。是的，派对城（Party City）的骷髅，难道真的是我们能做到的极限吗？
We just get out of town? Look, I think that we need a little less capitalism in funerals and a little more Party City. Only partly ironically. I've kind of been conditioned growing up to think that skeletons sound like
我们就不能离开这个小镇吗？听着，我认为葬礼中的资本主义应该少一点，派对城的元素应该多一点。这并非完全是在开玩笑。我从小受到的条件反射让我觉得骷髅听起来就像
Cab Calloway. That's what I imagined that they sound like. Have you seen that skeleton that they're selling now that's like 20 feet tall or something they haven't yeah no all the all the the goobers over in places like trustful i mean when they're trying to outdo each other with their halloween decorations when they're not the people like so against how we this is like doing a cheerleader triangle more. Like I thought,
卡布·卡洛维（Cab Calloway）。那就是我脑海中它们的声音。你见过他们现在卖的那种大概20英尺高的巨型骷髅吗？他们有吗？没有，所有那些住在特拉斯特富尔（Trustful）之类地方的傻瓜们——我的意思是，当他们试图在万圣节装饰上超越彼此时，当他们不是那些强烈反对我们——这就像是在进行啦啦队金字塔排练一样。就像我以为，
I remember there's, there's one house over on trustful clay road where they always go all out every year. Like I deliberately try and drive right there in October. It was like, Ooh, what are they doing? And I remember last time they had like three of those giant skeletons out like doing different various things.
我记得，在特拉斯特富尔克莱路（Trustful Clay Road）上有这样一栋房子，他们每年都会全力以赴。我故意在十月份试图开车去那儿。当时我想：“噢，他们今年在搞什么花样？”我记得上次他们把三个那种巨大的骷髅拿出来摆成各种不同的姿势。
I was like, you guys have maybe a little too much disposable income. Even that much. I thought there was some serious investment in the going brain of a giant skeleton. There's a lot more of them than there were in the P.T. Barnum days.
当时我想：你们的闲钱可能有点太多了。甚至连那种程度的钱都有。我以为他们在巨型骷髅的研发上投入了巨资。现在的巨型骷髅比P·T·巴纳姆（P.T. Barnum）那个年代要多得多。
Yes. It's more about the cost of having to have an entire storage room to store all of your bones. Mass skeletons. the cost of having to have an entire storage room to store all of your like that foam. Mass scale. Well, now someone can go do the Cardiff giant hoax, but now they actually have a skeleton to build off of.
是的。这更多地关乎必须拥有一个整个储藏室来存放你所有的骨头的成本。巨型骷髅。拥有一个整个储藏室来存放你所有的像那种泡沫塑料一样的骨头的成本。大规模骨架。好吧，现在有人可以去重演卡迪夫巨人骗局（Cardiff giant hoax），但现在他们实际上有了一个可以依此建造的骨架。
Yeah, I don't think that works anymore now that you can get them at Sam's Club. Hey guys, look what I dug up in my yard, you know. The origin of P.T. Barnum's circus, for anyone unfamiliar, is that he made and buried a giant fake skeleton and then dug it up and set it in a field and would charge you a nickel to look like a peak. But in fact, the start of that, actually, it was a grift of a grift. Yeah, but he copied the farmer.
是的，我觉得现在既然你在山姆会员店（Sam's Club）就能买到，那种把戏就失效了。嘿，伙计们，看看我在院子里挖出了什么，你知道的。对于不了解的人来说，P·T·巴纳姆马戏团的起源是，他制作并埋葬了一个巨大的假骨架，然后把它挖出来放在一块田里，向你收一镍币来看这个奇观。但事实上，这一切的开始，其实是一场骗局中的骗局。是的，但他模仿了那个农民。
He tried to buy it from the farmer for 20 bucks and the farmer said no and he made it. There was a farmer who was just like basically tired of all his his extremely religious friends like talking what he considered gobbledygook so it's like he said it was like an enochian giant didn't he like it was from rebel times yeah he was riffing on biblical giants because he was basically like i'm gonna show these these fucking goobers like that that no this is this is dumb i'm gonna trick all of you but then pt barnum saw it was like this is dumb. I'm going to trick all of you. But then P.T. Barnum saw it and was like, this is really cool. Can I buy it from you? And he said no. So P.T. Barnum just made his own and claimed it was the original
他曾试图以20美元向农民买下它，但农民拒绝了，于是他自己做一个。当时有个农民基本上厌倦了他那些极其宗教的朋友们谈论他认为全是胡言乱语的东西，所以这就好比他说，这就像是一个以诺巨神（Enochian giant），难道他不是这样吗，就像它是来自《创世记》时代一样？是的，他在借用圣经里的巨人梗，因为他基本上是在想：“我要让这些该死的傻瓜们看看，不，这太蠢了，我要戏弄你们所有的人。”但随后P·T·巴纳姆看到了，并觉得：“这太酷了。我能从你这儿买下它吗？”那人说不。所以P·T·巴纳姆就自己做一个，并声称那是原件，
because P.T. Barnum had no shame and was incredibly based. Yeah, that's why that movie that came out a couple years ago, I didn't see it, but the trailer, they were like, he just wanted children to smile. I was like, no, this is not what P.T. Barnum did i said that to jenny the other day
因为P·T·巴纳姆毫无羞耻心，而且极其硬核。是的，这就是为什么几年前上映的那部电影——我没看，但看预告片时，他们表现得好像他只是想让孩子们微笑。我当时就想：不，这根本不是P·T·巴纳姆做的事。我前几天对珍妮说过，
like there's some scene jackman being saying to the bearded lady like they don't understand you now yes well one day it's like the real pt barnum would have been like no get out big get back out there sweetie you got like this is it's such a it's such a weird screenwriting thing that like whenever you buy the rights to some horrible american family or american story you have to make it about how they really just wanted to build a family wait for when they try and rehabilitate the sacklers with like a nice dramatic like a romantic comedy yeah i don't know death in film that's that's that's another direction that's kind of interesting um well uh i don't know i don't want to keep you guys too much um is there you know anything that
就像里面有什么场景是休·杰克曼对胡子女士说“他们现在还不理解你”，是的，好吧，真正的P·T·巴纳姆当时会说：“不，滚开，快回到台上去，亲爱的，你得像——”这真是一种奇怪的编剧手法，每当你买下某个可怕的美国家庭或美国故事的版权时，你都得把它拍成关于他们其实只是想建立一个家庭的故事。等着看他们什么时候试图把萨克勒家族（Sacklers）塑造成那种优美的戏剧性浪漫喜剧吧。是的，我不知道，电影中的死亡，那——那是另一个挺有意思的方向，嗯，呃，我不知道，我不想占用你们太多时间，嗯，有没有什么——
we don't get to or something that seems seems relevant or i remember the reason i started talking about the giant skeleton thing is um alex is she's a really good local therapist her name just started ember wellness if you're looking for, um, that she had one of the giant skeletons in her yard and we were like brainstorming, trying to come up with ways to keep it around for all the holidays, you know, like putting it in a Turkey costume or, but put bunny ears on it or, you know, have like a, you know, nativity of skeletons or something. And it was like, we should bring back the,... I love that. To the awareness of death. These other holidays. It's for now. The chickens and the baby bunnies are hatching but just wait.
我们没有聊到或者似乎很相关的事情？我记得我开始谈论巨型骷髅这件事的原因是，嗯，亚历克斯，她是一位非常优秀的本地治疗师，她的名字叫“余烬健康”（Ember Wellness），如果你在寻找的话，呃，她院子里就有一个巨型骷髅，我们当时在集思广益，试图想出办法让它在所有的节日里都留下来，你知道的，比如给它穿上火鸡服装，或者，但是给它戴上兔子耳朵，或者，你知道的，搞一个骷髅耶稣诞生场景什么的。当时的感觉是，我们应该把……我太喜欢这个了。重新唤起对死亡的意识。这些别的节日。现在正是时候。小鸡和兔宝宝正在孵化，但请等等。
Hang on a minute. I actually, and I still have... Stephanie will have to go away. I've got a half skeleton that I actually built up into a little ground burster zombie and it was it was the weirdest like most uncomfortable process because the way you do it is you just start with one of these plastic skeletons and start stretching candy hose over it
等一会儿。我其实，而且我仍然有——斯蒂芬妮得走开。我有一个半截的骨架，我实际上把它做成了一个从地下钻出来的僵尸，那是我经历过的最奇怪、最让人感到不舒服的过程，因为你制作它的方法就是从其中一个塑料骷髅开始，然后开始把丝袜套在它上面，
so you feel like you're like doing some some real weird like serial killer stuff but once you get that that painting that forms like that forms the basis. No, Mom, I was just making a Halloween decoration. No, that's not what you think. But you start painting on liquid latex and you actually get like an okay skin. It starts to look kind of like a mummy. And
所以你会觉得自己像是在做什么非常诡异的连环杀人犯的勾当，但一旦你完成了那一步，那就是成型的基础——不，妈妈，我只是在做一个万圣节装饰。不，不是你想的那样。但你开始刷上液体乳胶，然后你真的能得到一种还算可以的皮肤。它开始看起来有点像木乃伊。而且
I dressed him. I went to the thrift store and found a child-sized suit and put this half-skeleton to the suit. And so I had him like burst out of the ground one of these Halloweens. I need to put him out again. Maybe I will for this year. I'm going to put it in the tabard yard before
我给他穿上了衣服。我去旧货店找了一套儿童尺寸的西装，把这个半截骨架塞进了西装里。所以在其中一个万圣节，我让他像这样从地下钻出来。我得把他再摆出来。也许今年我会这么做。我打算在31号之前把他放在前院里。
the 31st. You're welcome to just turn left at the... I'm just going to start... What I'll start doing is I'll start cranking out. I'll get better and better at making these corpses. I'll start cranking them out and I'll just start leaving them at your therapy place over time. And you can do them whatever the heck you want. I'm just leaving them there.
欢迎你在……左转。我打算开始——我将要开始做的是，我会开始批量制作。我会越来越擅长制作这些尸体。我会开始批量生产，然后随着时间的推移，我会把它们留在你们的诊所里。你们可以随心所欲地用它们来做任何该死的事情。我只是把它们留在那里。
They'll already be dressed. They'll be good to go. You just decide what you want to do. Well, we can totally use it as a topic for therapy. It's like a person who comes in. Well, it's just you have yourself in the main chair of the office. Then you have the skeleton, a corner chair.
他们早就穿好衣服了。他们随时准备好了。你只需要决定你想做什么。好吧，我们完全可以把它当作治疗的话题。就像一个来访者走进来。好吧，就是你自己坐在办公室的主椅上。然后你有一个骷髅，一把角落的椅子。
And the thing is, if anyone asks about it, just pretend it's not there. Just like, what are you talking about? What skeleton? Yeah. You just have it on a little,
关键是，如果有人问起，就假装它不存在。就像，你在说什么？什么骷髅？对。你把它放在一个小小的，
a painting couch is the skeleton of the room right now with us. Yeah. You talk about it's mom issues. Yeah, this was, um, this was a lot, a lot of fun.
画室沙发就是房间里现在跟我们在一起的那个骷髅。对。你谈论的是妈妈的问题。对，这个，嗯，这个非常有意思。
Thank you. Thank you for inviting me on. Cause I do, I do love to, in my own amateurish way, talk shop about death stuff. It's a lot of fun. Yeah.
谢谢。谢谢你邀请我来。因为我确实，我非常喜欢，用我这种业余的方式，聊聊关于死亡的话题。这很有趣。对。
Anything we don't get to you, you're all, uh, I mean, there's, I mean, I, I don't,
我们没聊到的任何事情，你都，呃，我是说，有，我是说，我，我没有，
I'm about to go back to the office and move furniture. So I'm not in a huge rush, but, um, you know, I don't want to keep you all past the expiry. Any topics of interest or anything? Well, I'll say if any viewers want to continue reading about any of this stuff again,
我正要回办公室搬家具。所以我不是很着急，但是，你知道，我不想耽误大家太久。有什么感兴趣的话题吗？好吧，我会说，如果任何观众想继续阅读这些相关的内容，
any of the Caitlin Dougherty books are fantastic. And, I mean, even just her YouTube channel is great. Her video explaining New Orleans oven crepes is literally what verbatim I probably quoted to you a little while back, Joe. I always blank on
凯特琳·道蒂（Caitlin Daugherty）的任何一本书都非常棒。而且，我是说，甚至她的YouTube频道也很棒。她那个解释新奥尔良烤炉薄饼的视频，字面意思可能就是我前不久对你引用的，乔。我总是记不清
the title. Is it from here? Because it's something to eternity, but I always did the one that I believe it's from here to
书名。它是从这儿开始的吗？因为它是关于通往永恒什么的，但我总是以为那本是《从这儿到
eternity. If it isn't from here to eternity, the movie from the 70s where they make out of the waves though, they have the same title.
永恒》。如果不是《从这儿到永恒》，那是70年代那部他们在海浪中亲热的电影，不过它们名字一样。
Is it a different one? No, I wasn't talking about like they parody it in airplane because when they have the same title is it a different one no i wasn't you know what i'm talking about like they parody it in airplane because when the wave comes up there's like crabs and fish and stuff i wasn't even like did she name it then even my parents eyes then like good lord yeah i have no idea i mean that's that's um i remember recently when that movie the whale came out uh real quick just wanted to look at IMDb. I was curious. I like Britain and Frasier.
是另外一本吗？不，我不是说像他们在《空前绝后满天飞》里恶搞的那样，因为当它们名字一样时，是另外一本吗？不，我不是，你知道我在说什么吗？就像他们在《空前绝后满天飞》里恶搞的那样，因为当海浪涌上来时，有螃蟹和鱼什么的，我甚至不是像——那是她当时起的名字吗？甚至在我父母眼里，就像天哪，对，我完全不知道。我是说，那是，嗯，我记得最近那部电影《鲸鱼》上映时，呃，我只是想快速看一下IMDb。我很好奇。我喜欢布兰登和弗雷泽。
And then when I saw like four other titles also called The Whale, I was like, Aaron Oski, come on, man. Couldn't you like the the citation? I bet no one's done that. That probably doesn't have the same kick as the whale. If you're watching people make out in the water in waves, then you've got not only the wrong medium but the wrong book. Caitlin Daugherty, from here you turn.
然后当我看到其他四个也叫《鲸鱼》的标题时，我就想，达伦·阿罗诺夫斯基，拜托，老兄。你就不能引经据典一下吗？我敢说没人这么干过。那可能没有《鲸鱼》那么带劲。如果你看到人们在海浪中亲热，那你不仅找错了媒介，还找错了书。凯特琳·道蒂，从这儿你转。
From here to eternity, if you're reading about people making out in the waves and not about the interesting Tarajan culture from Indonesia, then yes, you have picked up the wrong book. Alice, you got anything? No, not in particular. There's the book Stiff by Mary Roach, which is a really, really great book.
《从这里到永恒》，如果你读的是人们在海浪中亲热，而不是关于印度尼西亚有趣的托拉查文化，那么是的，你选错书了。爱丽丝，你有什么要补充的吗？不，没有特别的。有一本玛丽·罗奇写的《打包去火星》或《募尸所》，那是一本非常非常棒的书。
Thank you for bringing that one up. That one's also excellent. Yeah, about how they take care of bodies and just everything to do with what we're talking about, basically. They go into the body form briefly in that book as well. And a lot of the topics, at least regarding the American funeral industry, there's a book from the 1950s called The American Way of Death. My mother, God bless her, found a first edition at the thrift store. That was one of my prized old books. Yeah.
谢谢你提到那本。那本也很出色。对，关于他们如何处理遗体，以及基本上所有与我们正在谈论的话题相关的事情。那本书里也简短地探讨了遗体的形态。而且很多话题，至少关于美国殡葬业，有一本1950年代的书叫《美国死亡方式》。我母亲，上帝保佑她，在旧货店里找到了一本初版。那是我珍视的旧书之一。对。
And the funny thing is I flipped through it and I was just shaking my head because all the problems it mentions in this book published in the 1950s, exact same issues we have today. It has not changed one iota. The prices have just changed because of inflation. That's it. That is it. They probably have some sillier names. You the the carnival barker you know upsell is it still the same people who manufacture is it like caskets and things like i wonder if it's sort of is it sort of a monopoly i know luxottica i'm pretty sure hearses are a monopoly because those are literally made to order. They don't make
有趣的是，我翻看了一下，直摇头，因为这本书在1950年代出版时提到的所有问题，跟我们今天遇到的完全是一模一样。它一点也没有改变。价格只是因为通货膨胀而变了。仅此而已。仅此而已。他们可能有一些更愚蠢的名字。你那个狂欢节叫卖式的推销，你知道的，加价推销，制造骨灰盒和这些东西的还是那些人吗？我不知道这算不算是一种垄断？我知道陆逊梯卡眼镜（Luxottica），但我很确定灵车是一种垄断，因为那些真的是按需定制的。他们不制作
hearses unless you order one. Oh. Fun fact. That would be a good small business. Sounds like good money. Yeah. That would be one area that, yeah, good small business.
灵车，除非你订购。哦。冷知识。那会是一个很好的小生意。听起来很赚钱。对。那会是一个，是的，不错的小生意。
Do that in the funeral industry. We should have a Ma and Pop's casket store. They're legally required to take a casket if you order it from outside the funeral home. Never let them tell you otherwise. Right.
在殡葬业里做这个。我们应该开一家夫妻老婆店的骨灰盒店。法律规定，如果你从殡葬馆外面订购骨灰盒，他们必须接受。永远别让他们对你谎称不能这样。对的。
Yeah, and they don't tell you that you can get you can choose cremation either. They like wait for you to bring that up or they try to move really quickly through that it is wild what they put i mean it just is you know do you want fries with that and you want to supersize it i mean it just continues yeah like come in this room and look at these three caskets that are here that you can choose between and then choose the vault and we're because that's a big you know we don't even talk about the vault but that's a big thing do you want a crying angel to go on top of that yeah well and
对，而且他们不会告诉你，你也可以选择火灾，哦不，火化。他们会等着你主动提出来，或者他们试图非常快地略过这一点。他们提供的那些东西太疯狂了，我的意思是，这就像，你知道的，“你要点薯条吗？”和“你要加大份吗？”我的意思是，它一直在继续。对，就像“来这个房间看看这三个你可以选择的骨灰盒，然后选择墓穴”，因为那是一个巨大的，你知道的，我们甚至不谈论墓穴，但那是一个重要的事情，“你想在上面放一个哭泣的天使吗？”对，好吧，而且
it was with my grandmother's funeral my aunt was very insistent she was like the we're gonna get the the most basic basket which was beautiful and just wood and you know they act like that's the one that you know you're really skimping on if you get but it's actually the prettiest one to me but she was like no but we're spending the money on the vault that's that's where you spend the money is on the vault and not on the casket so that but i don't know i mean i was like okay or vaults are actually far more for aesthetic considerations of the lens rather than actually for anything protective. Vaults don't, don't, if it, the thing particular in this, we're about to get into a little bit of gross detail here.
在我奶奶的葬礼上，我姑姑非常坚持，她说我们要买最基础的那个骨灰盒，那其实很漂亮，只是木头的，你知道的，他们表现得好像如果你选那个，你就是在吝啬，但其实在我看来它是最漂亮的。但她说，不，我们要把钱花在墓穴上，那是你花钱的地方，钱要花在墓穴上，而不是骨灰盒上。所以，但，我不知道，我的意思是，当时我想，好吧。其实墓穴更多是出于镜头的审美考虑，而不是为了任何保护作用。墓穴不，如果它，特别是在这里，我们要讲一点恶心的细节了。
But while we're talking about it, one of the issues with any kind of, if they tell you like, oh, we got a, we've got a ceiling casket with gaskets and a sealing vault is you don't want everything perfectly sealed. That promotes anaerobic decomposition, stuff that exists without oxygen, and that's the nasty decom. You want the body to be exposed to the elements to a certain degree, even if it's just allowing
但既然我们在聊这个，任何种类的——如果他们告诉你，哦，我们有一个带垫圈的密封骨灰盒和一个密封墓穴，其中一个问题是，你并不希望一切都完全密封。那会促进厌氧分解，也就是在没有氧气的情况下存在的分解，那是令人讨厌的分解。你希望尸体在一定程度上接触外界元素，哪怕只是允许
water and some air in there. Otherwise, you get soup. To put you get soup. To put it bluntly. Wow. Yeah. Well, they crack it anyway, because they want you to decompose, you know, and they bury you. Yeah, yeah. It's just that there have
水和一些空气进去。否则，你会得到一锅汤。直白点说，你会得到一锅汤。说得直白点。哇。对。好吧，他们无论如何都会把它弄破，因为他们希望你分解，你知道的，当你被埋葬的时候。对，对。只是
been instances in the past in improperly maintained mausoleums, they have something called exploding casket syndrome, which is when the pressure builds up too much and the front of the mausoleum begins to leak. Yeah, it's corpse disposal is a gross
过去有过这样的例子，在维护不善的陵墓中，会发生一种叫做“骨灰盒爆炸综合征”的现象，也就是当压力积聚过大时，陵墓的前部开始渗漏。是的，处理尸体是一件
thing. I mean, probably... What's the average price? I mean, if you go in, you get the hearse, you get the pink lacquered casket with the... What's the average funeral cost? They're probably going to try and sell you on a standard traditional funeral, which is basically the full package. They want you to just get them. What's the average funeral cost? They're probably going to try and sell you on a standard traditional funeral, which is basically the full package.
很恶心的事情。我的意思是，可能……平均价格是多少？我的意思是，如果你进去，你要了灵车，你要了那个粉红色漆面的骨灰盒，带着……平均葬礼费用是多少？他们可能会试图向你推销标准的传统葬礼，这基本上是全套服务。他们希望你直接买下整套。平均葬礼费用是多少？他们可能会试图向你推销标准的传统葬礼，这基本上是全套服务。
They want you to just get everything. At least here in Alabama, I think I've seen prices around probably you'd be spending $5,000 to $6,000. Wow. Basically, the world's worst mixer.
他们希望你把什么都买下。至少在这里阿拉巴马州，我想我看到的费用大概是，你得花5000到6000美元。哇。基本上是世界上最糟糕的混合器。
Again, that's why we cut out with my grandmother we cut out the funeral entirely and did a crypt side something like there were there wasn't even anyone from the funeral home there it was literally just us the family you hang out in that little room with the you know greece greek pictures and uh no we had little paintings and yeah we hung out we hung out in the mausoleum itself. We were in there. And I mean, that is nice. A properly maintained mausoleum
再说一次，这就是为什么我奶奶的葬礼我们完全省去了传统葬礼，而是在墓穴边举行了一些仪式，甚至没有殡葬馆的人在那里， literalmente 只有我们家人。你和那些希腊风格画作呆在那个小房间里，呃，不，我们有一些小画作，是的，我们在陵墓本身里面闲逛。我们就在里面。我的意思是，这挺好的。维护良好的陵墓
usually does not smell like anything. And it's very, very quiet. I used to, that cemetery she's buried in, it's right across from a big shopping center in Trussell. I used to work at a couple of stores over there. And I remember when I got set up on my break, I was like, I've got to get away from just everybody. I don't want to see my co-workers'
通常没有任何气味。而且非常非常安静。我以前，她安葬的那个墓地，就在特鲁斯维尔一个大购物中心的对面。我以前在那边的好几家店工作过。我记得当我获得休息时间时，我想，我必须离开所有人。我不想看到同事的
faces. I don't want to see the customers. I don't see anybody. I would actually just drive across the street and sit in that mausoleum. I wouldn't be doing anything more, but I'd just be on my phone scrolling through mods for Skyrim or whatever. Just sitting in the... Because it's quiet. It's peaceful.
脸。我不想看到顾客。我不想看到任何人。我其实会开车过马路，坐在那个陵墓里。我不会做什么特别的事，我只是拿着手机滚动浏览《上古卷轴5：天际》的模组或者别的什么。就坐在……因为那里很安静。很平和。
No one's going to bother me. It's a good place to pay Dark Souls. Yes, an excellent place. Yeah, lots of quiet and solitude unless someone tries to come kick you out or something. I guess if it's your family grip, they can't, right? Well, yeah.
没有人会打扰我。这是个玩《黑暗之魂》的好地方。是的，一个极好的地方。对，有很多安静和孤独，除非有人试图把你赶出去什么的。我想如果是你家族的墓穴，他们不能这么做，对吧？好吧，是的。
Yeah, we're not... Yeah, if you're not creating those disturbances, it's fine. But at least that's also the nice thing about my family is whenever whenever we we have a loved one pass on, it's generally not a super somber affair because, I mean, we'll have some tears. But often it's a it's a circle of telling funny stories about the person. Telling funny stories or making jokes about our own future demises. I remember mom at my great-grandmother's funeral made a quip about, you know,
是的，我们没有……是的，如果你没有制造那些骚扰，那就没问题。但至少这也是我家庭好的一面，每当我们的亲人离世时，通常都不是一个超级阴郁的事件，因为，我的意思是，我们会流一些眼泪。但通常这是一个围坐在一起讲逝者趣事的小圈子。讲讲趣事，或者开开我们自己未来死亡的玩笑。我记得我曾祖母葬礼上，妈妈开玩笑说，你知道的，
we ought to, if we cremated her, what if we threw her in with a bag of popcorn? Like, and popped it and then called the game What's Eating Mom? It's just, like, and popped it, and then called the game What's Eating Mom? It's just, again, like, these very, like, these very morbid jokes, but that gallows humor, at least for us, it really does help.
我们应该，如果我们火化了她，如果我们把她和一包爆米花一起扔进去会怎么样？就像，把它爆开，然后把这局游戏叫作“什么在吃妈妈”？这就像，再次，这些非常，这些非常病态的幽默，但这种黑色幽默，至少对我们来说，确实很有帮助。
Like, because, I mean, my family is pretty down-to-earth and logical, and we all know that, you know, you know, death will come eventually, and we just, we're all kind of planning for, hey hey don't make a big fuss out of it and have a few larps because i mean that's the only thing you can do at that juncture is yeah have your tears but then laugh about all the good times we had when i think
因为，我的意思是，我的家人相当脚踏实地且合乎逻辑，我们都知道，你知道，死亡终究会到来，我们都在为此做计划，嘿，嘿，别大惊小怪的，开怀大笑几次吧，因为我的意思是，在那个人生节点上你唯一能做的事就是，流下你的眼泪，然后笑着谈论我们度过的所有美好时光。当我想到
therapeutically and spiritually and and philosophically it's not that death is absurd it's the death kind of makes life absurd you know that's like we feel like we really care so much about you know getting the iphone you know 13 or whatever you know it's kind of helpful to pick up your skull and look into its york size and be like yeah you know what maybe this is kind of i just want you to know if i'm ever in the unfortunate circumstance where i must eulogize you one of the things i am going to mention is you have is your cackle is one of the things I wanted to talk about explicitly because you have one of the most infectious laughs I've ever heard on a person. And then right when you finish the line and the audience laughs, you'll hear the cackle coming from the crypt.
从治疗、精神和哲学的角度来看，并不是死亡很荒谬，而是死亡让生命变得荒谬，你知道的，这就像我们觉得我们非常在乎得到iPhone 13什么的，你知道的，去捡起一个头骨，看着它约克大小的眼眶，然后说，好吧，你知道吗，也许这其实挺……我只想让你知道，如果我有一天不幸必须为你致悼词，我要提到的事情之一就是你的咯咯笑声，这是我想明确谈论的事情之一，因为你的笑声是我听过最具有感染力的人类笑声之一。然后就在你说完台词，观众大笑的时候，你会听到从墓穴里传来的咯咯笑声。
It'll be too late. I remember way too many times you and I have been joking about something, and I've been doubled over laughing. Honestly, not because even what we were talking about in the beginning was that funny. It's because you're laughing so hard, it's making you laugh. There was a pretty good riff about a family
那就太迟了。我记得有太多次你和我都在拿某件事开玩笑，我笑得直不起腰来。老实说，甚至不是因为我们一开始谈论的事情有多么好笑。而是因为你笑得太厉害了，这让我不得不跟着笑。关于一个家庭被
being upsold. I won't repeat. Yeah, I couldn't breathe. Yeah, I do. I do remember that day. I'm glad we got off the interstate with this. I literally had to pull over.
诱导升级消费，有一个挺不错的梗。我就不重复了。对，我当时笑得喘不过气来。是的，我确实。我确实记得那天。我很庆幸我们当时把车开下了州际公路。我 literalmente 不得不把车停在路边。
Yeah, I remember we were like, man, I'm glad that we were able to pay attention to driving and laugh that hard. Well, I mean, just to kind of close out, I mean, do you have anything from a more of a therapeutic perspective, Alice? I mean, I do think that a lot of times one of the more damaging things we can do as therapists is avoid something that the patient wants to go through. And our fear that they won't be comfortable with it means we avoid things. And a lot of times that's death. I mean, when I bring up kind of uncomfortable topics, but especially the fear of death, I mean, I think that's when people kind of bloom and open up because no one else gave them space to talk about that. It's not really that
是的，我记得我们当时说，天哪，我很庆幸我们既能注意开车又能笑得那么厉害。好吧，我的意思是，为了做个总结，爱丽丝，从一个更具治疗的角度来看，你有什么看法吗？我的意思是，我确实认为很多时候，作为治疗师，我们能做的最具破坏性的事情之一就是回避患者想要深入探讨的事情。我们担心他们会对此感到不舒服，这意味着我们在回避问题。很多时候，那就是死亡。我的意思是，当我提出一些令人尴尬的话题，尤其是对死亡的恐惧时，我认为正是这个时候人们才会真正绽放和敞开心扉，因为没有其他人给他们空间去谈论这个。这其实并不是因为
we are afraid of it as much as that we are afraid other people are afraid of it. And then that makes us feel alone. You know, I see that dynamic a lot with a lot of issues yeah yeah and um i don't mean to keep bringing it back to kids but i feel like with teenagers that it's uh like honoring because they actually want to talk about death or they're like it's a comfortable not comfortable topic but sort of you know insofar as it can be comfortable. I feel like teenagers are a good, are the demographic that like want to talk about it, scares them, but they also don't, you know, they're kind of aware that it's this thing that all the people in their lives, the adults don't really talk about. And, and that's around the age too, where start where you've maybe had a few a couple people your own age who've died like going to a funeral of another kid was is a big is was a big
我们害怕它，而是因为我们害怕别人害怕它。这让我们感到孤独。你知道，我在很多问题上都看到了这种动态。是的，是的，嗯，我不是故意老是把话题扯回小孩子身上，但我觉得对于青少年来说，这是一种尊重，因为他们实际上想谈论死亡，或者对他们来说这是一个舒适的——也不是舒适的话题，但某种程度上（就其舒适度而言）我觉得青少年是一个很好的群体，是那种想要谈论它的人口统计群体，它让他们害怕，但他们也不，你知道的，他们有点意识到这是他们生活中所有人、成年人们并不真正谈论的事情。而且，这也是那个年龄段，你可能已经经历过几个同龄人去世的情况——去参加另一个孩子的葬礼，对我来说是一个非常重大的事情。
thing place for me yeah um but i'm trying to think um yeah i don't know was there is there any did you have any clients in particular that you remember kind of working with around this? Yeah, there's there's a lot of cases. I mean, teenagers is a good point, though. I mean, like you I'm talking I started with a joke about how people dress at Hot Topic that were gothic when I was in high school. But I mean, there's a reason that teenagers do that right like they're kind of being like you know i'm not just i'm edgy i'm different but also like i'm okay with this thing you know that you don't know i'm gonna remind you of yeah something subversive you can't control me yeah yeah and and one of that is kind of i mean that's sort of when
嗯……但我在想，嗯，是的，我不知道，你有没有特别记得和哪些来访者围绕这个主题工作过？是的，有很多案例。我的意思是，青少年是一个很好的切入点。我的意思是，就像你一样，我一开始开玩笑说我上高中时那些哥特风格的人在Hot Topic（服装店）是怎么穿衣服的。但我的意思是，青少年这样做是有原因的，对吧？他们有点像在说，你知道的，我不只是，我很前卫，我很与众不同，但同时也是，我能接受这件你所不知道的事情，我要提醒你注意它。是的，某种颠覆性的东西，你无法控制我。是的，是的，其中之一就是，我的意思是，那就是当
you are you know you're wearing an auk and that maybe is more 80s gothic than 2005 you know but like like wearing the you know dressing uh like you know death from sandman and uh you know the the all black even black lipstick and i mean a lot of that is kind of saying i'm comfortable with the other side i see through the lies of society man you know when you're when you're 13 um in a way that's a healthy developmental phase, you know, to say this thing's kind of scary, but I'm going to sit with it and I'm going to, you know, play with other people's reaction to this thing that they're uncomfortable with. It's what you're supposed to do when you're a teenager, I guess. I mean, I guess same thing as like sex education is if you have death phobic, you know, if you're death phobic, then it's like you're not doing,
你，你知道的，你戴着生命之符（Ankh），那可能更像是80年代的哥特风，而不是2005年的，你知道的，但就像穿着，你知道的，打扮得像《睡魔》里的死亡，你知道的，全身黑色，甚至涂黑色口红，我的意思是，这在很大程度上是在说，我能坦然面对另一面，我看穿了社会的谎言，老兄，你知道的，当你13岁的时候……在某种程度上，这是一个健康的成长阶段，你知道的，去说这东西有点可怕，但我要和它共存，我要，你知道的，去玩味其他人对这个让他们感到不舒服的东西的反应。我想，这就是你十几岁时应该做的事。我的意思是，我想这就像性教育一样，如果你有恐死症，你知道的，如果你有恐死症，那么这就好像你没有帮到
you're not doing the teenager any any favors by not not exposing them to it and teaching them something about it in a safe a safe situation yeah actually i had mentioned the onk house what i know that means life right but we kind of associate it with that do you know that yeah yeah i'm not in the 80s what did no, that's why I was saying you're wearing an onk. That's why I mentioned it. I wasn't. Yeah. Oh, no. I mean. Yeah.
青少年任何忙，因为你没有让他们接触它，也没有在一个安全的情况下教给他们一些关于它的知识。是的，其实我刚才提到了生命之符（Ankh），我知道那意味着生命，对吧？但我们往往把它和死亡联系在一起，你知道那一点吗？对，对，我在80年代……什么也没有，这就是为什么我说你戴着生命之符。这就是我提到它的原因。我不是。是的。哦，不。我是说。是的。
That's cool. So to me, so the cross is representative of. So I have I have some different some divergent views about this, but the cross is representative of like the energy goes up and kind of stops on the like it's and then goes back into the earth but with the ankh it it's a circle at the top so you have the where the energy um stops on the side but it it keeps circulating so it's like it's more of a like christianity is you know talks about being about eternal life and but they really just focus on death i mean it just feels like it's all about death like no sooner do you hear about baby jesus when you're little then you know they kill him off
这很酷。所以对我来说，十字架代表着……所以我有一些不同的、不同的看法，但十字架代表着能量上升，然后在某个地方停下，就像这样，然后又回到地球里；但对于生命之符来说，它的顶部是一个圆圈，所以能量在两侧停下的地方，它会继续循环，所以它更像是一种——比如基督教谈论的是永生，但他们实际上只关注死亡，我的意思是，感觉这一切都关乎死亡——当你还小的时候，你刚听说圣婴耶稣不久，你知道的，他们就把他弄死了，
and doesn't and i think the ankh um you know, from ancient Egypt is they really believed in the afterlife and in reincarnation. And it's kind of this symbol of life flowing with them and not just being like done. It's like everything flows. But it's such an interesting irony. and not just being like done. It's like everything flows. But it's such an interesting irony. I mean, you're talking about this life force or going back into whatever, but then there were the ultimate, you know,
而且难道不——我认为古埃及的生命之符，你知道的，他们真的相信来世和轮回。这有点像生命与他们一同流淌的象征，而不是像彻底结束了。这就像一切都在流淌。但这是一个多么有趣的讽刺。而不是像彻底结束了。这就像一切都在流淌。但这是一个多么有趣的讽刺。我的意思是，你在谈论这种生命力或回归某种状态，但他们却是终极的，你知道的，
preservationists. What is your mummies? Like you were supposed to be there forever in the room with the stuff, you know, because I'll need it. Well, and it's, it's more of like a preparation for reincarnation because a lot of the,
遗体保存主义者。木乃伊算什么？就像你应该永远待在那里，和那些东西呆在同一个房间里，你知道的，因为我会需要它们。好吧，而且，这更像是为转世做准备，因为很多，
you know, the tombs of Osiris was Isis trying to bring back her brother, love, her twin sister. Putting the body back together. Yeah, and putting it back on an electromagnetic grid so that certain things would line up with the sun and, know different um astrological signs waiting for you know trying to get the spirit to come back yeah i mean i think that's the ritual around death is that we have we know that this is an ending and we're trying to connect it to something else so whether you're doing that with you know astrology or community or uh you know more organized religion or in nature i mean that is the ritual around death as this is kind of an ending but yet things go on how do we point to that how do we symbolically recreate that and you know what what that thing is that you're connecting to the next step is going to be
你知道的，奥西里斯的陵墓是伊西斯试图复活她的兄弟、爱人、她的双胞胎姐妹。把身体重新拼凑起来。是的，把它重新连接到一个电磁网格上，以便某些东西与太阳对齐，你知道的，不同的占星符号，等待着——试图让灵魂回来。是的，我的意思是，围绕死亡的仪式就是我们知道这是一个结局，我们试图把它连接到别的东西上。所以无论你是通过占星术、社群、还是更有组织的宗教、或者是大自然来做到这一点，我的意思是，这就是围绕死亡的仪式：这是一个结局，但事情仍在继续，我们如何指出这一点？我们如何象征性地重现这一点？你知道的，你所连接的下一步是什么，将由你的信仰、你的文化和许多事情来决定，但所有这些死亡仪式都是为了做到这一点，你知道的，接下来会发生什么，对吧？对，对，是的。好吧，非常感谢你们坐下来谈论这些，这真的很棒，而且，祝大家万圣节快乐，祝你们有一个愉快的十月。如果你想长寿，就别唱歌。他们不需要你的歌声。你死了，你死了，你死了。你死了，脱离了这个世界。你永远不会有第二次机会。
informed by your faith and your culture and a lot of things but you know all those death rituals are an attempt to do that you know what comes what comes next right right yeah well i really appreciate you guys sitting down and talking um this is this is great and uh you know happy halloween everybody if you have a good october yeah don't sing if you want to live long. They have no use for your song. You're dead, you're dead, you're dead. You're dead and out of this world. You'll never get a second chance.
受你的信仰、文化和很多事物的启发，你知道，所有这些死亡仪式都是为了做到这一点，你知道接下来会发生什么，对吧？是的。嗯，我真的很感激你们坐下来谈谈，嗯，这太棒了，呃，你知道，大家万圣节快乐，如果你过了一个愉快的十月，是的，如果你想活得久一点就不要唱歌。他们不需要你的歌声。你死了，你死了，你死了。你死了，离开了这个世界。你永远不会有第二次机会。
Plan all your moves in advance. Stay dead, stay dead, stay dead. Stay dead and out of this world. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
提前计划好你所有的举动。保持死亡，保持死亡，保持死亡。保持死亡，脱离这个世界。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。